GOOD AND WELCOME THIS IS THE
ASSEMBLY BUDGET SUB COMMITTEE
NUMBER ONE ON HEALTH AND HUMAN
SERVICES. TODAY WE ARE FOCUSING
ON THE GOVERNOR'S APRIL FINANCE
LETTERS WHICH WERE RELEASED LAST
MONTH AS AN ADDITIONAL REQUEST
BUILDING UPON THE GOVERNOR'S
JANUARY BUDGET. WE ARE
ANTICIPATING RECEIVING THE
GOVERNOR'S MAY REVISION VERY
SOON BEFORE WE ACT ON THE
GOVERNOR'S REQUEST IN THE CLOSE
OUT OF OUR SUBCOMMITTEE'S WORK
WE WANT TO ENSURE THAT WE'VE
PROVIDED FOR PUBLIC EXPLANATION
AND DISCUSSION. THIS PROPOSAL.
IT'S IMPORTANT TO NOTE THAT
PUBLIC COMMENT IS WELCOME ON ANY
ISSUE IN THE AGENDA WHETHER IT
IS LISTED IN DISCUSSION OR NON
DISCUSSION ITEM. TODAY WE WILL
HAVE PANELISTS WERE PRESENTING
BOTH IN PERSON AND VIRTUALLY
USING ONLINE TECHNOLOGY. WE ARE
ACCEPTING PUBLIC COMMENT AT THE
END OF THIS HEARING BOTH IN THE
HEARING ROOM AND ON THE PHONE.
THE PHONE NUMBER TO CONNECT IS
ON THE COMMITTEE WEBSITE AND
SHOULD BE ON THE SCREEN IF YOU
ARE WATCHING OVER THE INTERNET.
THAT NUMBER TOLL FREE.
977-692-8957 AND THE PUBLIC
ACCESS CODE IS. ONE THREE ONE
FIVE FOUR FOUR FOUR. IF YOU
ENCOUNTER ANY PROBLEMS PLEASE
CONTACT THE ASSEMBLY BUDGET
COMMITTEE AT. 916-319-2090 NINE
AND A STAFF MEMBER WILL ASSIST
YOU. WE WILL BEGIN PUBLIC
COMMENT AFTER ALL MEMBERS HAVE
CONCLUDED THEIR QUESTIONS FOR
THE PANEL. THERE WILL BE NO
VOTES TAKEN IN TODAY'S HEARING
AS THIS IS AN INFORMATIONAL
HEARING TO DISCUSS THE GOVERNOR
ADDITIONAL APRIL BUDGET. BILLS I
WANT TO NOTE THAT WE ARE ALSO
ACCEPTING WRITTEN FEEDBACK
THROUGH THE SOMEONE EMAIL
ACCOUNT AND THE ADDRESS IS
BUDGET SUB ONE AT ASM DOT CA DOT
GOV. WE'RE GOING TO GO RIGHTS TO
THE APRIL REQUEST LISTED ON THE
DISCUSSION AGENDA FOR TODAY I
LOOK FORWARD TO HAVING THE
CONVERSATIONS WHICH WE HAVE
AGENDAS FOR TODAY. LET'S BEGIN
WITH THE PANEL FOR ISSUE ONE ON
THE EQUITY IMPLEMENTATION APRIL
BUDGET CHANGE PROPOSAL FROM THE
CALIFORNIA HEALTH AND HUMAN
SERVICES AGENCY. WE WILL HAVE
THREE PRESENTERS ON THIS PANEL
INCLUDING MARCELO RUIZ DIRECTOR
OF THE OFFICE OF EQUITY AT THE
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF SOCIAL
SERVICES- FOR WEB APPS. AS WELL
AS NINA WONG WHO IS WITH THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE AND SONYA
PADDOCK WITH THE L. A. R.
MOTIONS. AFTER HAVE BEEN. LET US
PLEASE BEGIN MARCELO RUIZ
DIRECTOR OF THE OFFICE OF EQUITY
FOR THE CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF
SOCIAL SERVICES PLEASE BEGIN
WHEN YOU ARE READY. GOOD
AFTERNOON CHAIR ARAMBULA AND
MEMBERS OF THE PANEL THANK YOU
VERY MUCH FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO
TESTIFY TODAY I'M AS YOU MENTION
MY PERSONAL MEMORIES I AM THE
DIRECTOR OF THE OFFICE OF EQUITY
WITH THE DEPARTMENT OF SOCIAL
SERVICES AND I AM. HERE ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA HEALTH
AND HUMAN SERVICES AGENCY TO
PROVIDE INFORMATION ON THE
EQUITY IMPLEMENTATION OF THE
SIXTEEN. AS YOU ARE AWARE CAL AG
JOHNSON SEEKING FIVE HUNDRED
THOUSAND DOLLARS FOR A ONE TIME
EXPENDITURE TO COURTNEY AND
INITIATE AN EQUITY STRATEGIC
PLAN THAT WOULD APPLY TO DEFINE
EQUITY GOALS A QUALIFIED CAL
CHIEF PASSED THE LARGEST AGENCY
THIS STATE AND ACROSS SEVERAL
LARGE WHAT THE PARKINSON FIVE
OFFICERS. THIS OF COURSE IS THE
REQUEST FOR COMES THE CON. OF A
VERY X. TIME FOR ACT INCOME.
WITH THE RIVER LACK MONTH BY THE
WAY HOUSE OF EQUITY. FROM NINE
NINE ZERO FEDERAL AGENCIES
INCLUDING THE FEDERAL HEALTH AND
HUMAN SERVICES DEPARTMENT- AS
WAS PROMISED BY THE BITING
HARRISON RESTRICTIONS EXECUTIVE
ORDER IN THE FIRST DAY IN
OFFICE. IT ALSO WITH THE
CONTACTS OF THE CREATION OF
RESOURCES AND CAPACITY ACROSS
STATE GOVERNMENT AND RECOGNITION
THAT ADDRESSING SOCIAL AND
HEALTH INEQUITIES AND IMPROVING
OUTCOMES FOR COMMUNITIES WHO
HAVE BEEN. HISTOICALLY EXCLUDED. FOR TWO REASONS YEAH AND
SUBJECTED TO THE- REQUIRES.
PRIORITIZATION AND DEDICATED
WITH. TO THAT WE HAVE A
COMMITMENT TO WHAT HE WORKS IN
OUR AGENCIES GUIDING PRINCIPLES
ARTICULATED EQUITY A QUORUM
VALUE AND COMMITTING TO PURSUE
SOCIAL AND RACIAL JUSTICE BY NOT
ONLY LIFTING ALL BOATS BUT
ESPECIALLY. THOSE FOLKS THAT
NEED TO BE LOOKED AT MORE. TWO
THREE FIVE INITIATIVE ALREADY
UNDERWAY WITH THE HELP OF HUMAN
SERVICE ENGINE. INCLUDING THE
HIRING OF A CHIEF EQUITY OFFICER
A LANGUAGE AXACT THE DEVELOPMENT
OF A LANGUAGE ACCESS PLAN FOR
ALL DEPARTMENTS WITHIN OUR
AGENCY AND THE TRAINING OF OUR
OF OUR STAFF AND LEADERSHIP WITH
IT WITHIN OUR AGENCY. AND NOW
THE NATIONAL ELEMENT OF THE WAR
WORK WHICH FALL INTO STRATEGIC
PLANS. MEETS THE NIGHT OF
FRAMEWORK ACOSTA WORK THAT IS
CURRENTLY FIVE LOGIN OR AGENCY
RATES CONNECTEDNESS WITH OTHER
OFFICERS INTERVENTION
INITIATIVES ACROSS THE
GOVERNMENT WHICH IS BOTH
INITIATIVES CURRENTLY UNDERWAY
IN THE OFFICE OF EMERGENCY
SERVICES ARMENTAL PROTECTION
AGENCY AND GOT HOT. AND
DIFFERENT WARRANT AN ENHANCED BY
ENGAGEMENT WITH COMMUNITY NEAR
ONE- CON MEETS THE WILL FOCUS ON
THE EXECUTION OF A CONTRACT THAT
PROVIDE THE NECESSARY EXPERTISE.
H. BURKE PROVISIONAL EXTERNAL.
TO DEVELOP A COMMON
UNDERSTANDING OF BARRIERS TO
EQUITY ACROSS COUNTY TO TRACK
THE PART. PROGRAMS AND- THAT
RESULTS IN THE LAND WHICH
DOCUMENTED STRATEGIC AND
OBJECTIVES IN YOUR TO WITH PLAN
TO PUBLICLY SHARE THOSE GOALS
AND OBJECTIVES AND ALSO BEGIN
EXECUTION ON THE PLANT INCLUDING
AND BODY. EQUITY INTO OUR
PRACTICE I WANT TO EMPHASIZE
THAT WE ANTICIPATE THAT THIS
WILL BE BOTH. METRIC ARE YOU
TURN WORKFORCE AND FOR APPROVED
OUTCOMES ON THE HAVE ONE
SPECIFIC QUESTIONS FOR A WHAT I
STRATEGIC PLAN WILL FOCUS MAJOR
PRO WERE WITH YOU JUST. AND
RELATED I WOULD ENSURE THAT HE
MUST SERVE PROGRAM RECEIPT WILL
ATTENTION TO PROGRAM IN THAT
AREA I'M I WANT TO WITH THE
PANEL AREN'T WITH PLAN TO BE
BROADLY ABOUT WHAT HE WITH IN
ACROSS THE- AND PROGRAMS AND
WITH THIS REMARKS ADDRESSES
APPLE APPS FOR TO WHICH AS
ACCESS CALICO CHILD CARE ARE. IN
HEALTHCARE AS WELL AS YEAH
CONDITION THE ONE TO THINKS
ABOUT ENACT IN EXISTING AND
LOOKING AT THE PORT PART OF OUR
NOW WHAT THE NEXT HOW AGENTS
EQUITY G. WON'T EVEN.
AND DEPARTMENTS AND WARM BREAD
THE FINAL BONNET. YOU ALSO ASKED
WHETHER THE CREATION OF THE CAL
INTO TRANCE EQUITY STRATEGIC
PLAN FOR DELAYING YOUR TERM WORK
THAT COULD BE DONE TO REDUCE
DISPARITIES THAT WE KNOW WORKS
IF NOT OUR PROGRAM AREAS AND HOW
WE WOULD INSURE THIS. WE WANT TO
ENSURE YOU THAT IT IS NOT OUR
INTENT TO DELAY ANY OF THE
CURRENT WORK THAT IS ALREADY
UNDER WAY IN OUR. DEPARTMENT-
LOW DEPARTMENTS WE WILL CONTINUE
ON THE- THAT WE HAVE OUR ENGAGED
. THAT DEVICE DISTRICT PLANS
ABOUT THINKING DEEP ABOUT HOW WE
CAN IMPROVE THE EQUITY AND
LEVERAGE EACH OTHER'S RESOURCES
AND UNDERSTANDING AND
STRATEGIES. THAT WE THAT WE HAVE
EMBEDDED IN OUR PROGRAM AREAS
ACROSS. THE DEPARTMENT THIS-
THIS EFFORT WILL NOT TAKE AWAY
FROM TE WORK THAT IS ALREADY
UNDER WAY BUT WOULD RATHER
COMPLEMENT. I THE MISSION IS AND
FINALLY WE ALL RECEIVE THE- OF-
PROBABLY WILL THINK ABOUT THAT-
URBAN WORLD COOL IN. TAX OF
DEMOGRAPHIC AND ASKED HOW THE
ACT WOULD PLAN WILL WILL UNDER
IN I DON'T THE SPOT- AT WE WANT
TO SHARE WITH YOU ABOUT YOUR-
EQUITY EFFECTS. ISSUE THAT WILL
BE A FACTOR IN EQUITY STRATEGIC
PLAN WE KNOW THAT THERE ARE
INEQUITIES ACROSS OUR STATE FOR
EXAMPLE IN THE PROCESS MEASURES
LIKE ACCESS TO HEALTHCARE
PROVIDERS AND OTHER SERVICES
ORANGE OUT. I'M MEASURES LIKE
I'M- LIFE EXPECTANCY WE KNOW
THAT THERE ARE THOSE. THE
GEOGRAPHIC AREA THIS OCCURS
HERBAL URBAN AND GROW AREA ALL
WE ARE AND RURAL AREAS THIS WILL
BE SOMETHING THAT WE CONSIDER IN
OUR PLANNING PROCESS SO WE'RE
NOT LEAVING ANY COMMUNITY BEHIND
AND I THINK RIGHT NOW GEOGRAPHIC
DATA IS GETTING MUCH MORE
GRANULAR ALLOWING US TO SPOT
INEQUITIES AND MAKE INFORMED
DECISIONS ABOUT INVESTMENTS AND
THE PLAN IS ANTICIPATING TO
ADDRESS THOSE ISSUES WITH THAT
CHAIR I WILL CLASS TO SEE IF
THERE ARE ANY. QUESTIONS YOU
PERMANENTLY. THE PERMANENT HUNG
THANK FOR THE FACT. LOL A GOOD
AFTERNOON- DOCTOR AMBULANCE WHEN
YOU PICK WITH THE L. A. O- WE'VE
REVIEWED THIS PARTICULAR REQUEST
AND DO NOT RAISE ANY CONCERNS.
THANK YOU I WILL BRING IT UP TO
THE DÍAS SO I WILL START MISS
RUIZ IF I CAN- THERE WAS A
QUESTION THAT- WANTED TO LOOK AT
HOW WE WERE GOING TO ENSURE THAT
OUR HUMAN SERVICES PROGRAMS WERE
GOING TO SEE SOME OF THE SAME.
ATTENTION THAT WE'VE- PROVIDED
TOWARDS OUR HEALTH PROGRAMS AND
WANTED TO HEAR EXPLICITLY FROM
YOU HOW WE WERE GOING TO ENSURE.
THAT HUMAN SERVICES WERE GOING
TO HAVE AND LENDS OF EQUITY- IN
PROGRAMS HOPING YOU CAN ADDRESS
THAT. ABSOLUTELY CHAIR SO AS YOU
ARE AWARE THERE ARE A NUMBER OF
INITIATIVES ALREADY UNDER WAY
WITHIN HUMAN SERVICES SHE WOULD-DRIVE IN EQUITY AND IN OUR
PROGRAMS. IN INCLUDING BANK CAL
OR IN CALIFORNIA CLASS LAST YEAR
DRAFT NEXT WEEK'S WITHIN OUR CAL
WORKS PROGRAM. OUT WHICH INVEST.
CALPERS TO ADDRESS. THE ISSUE AS
WELL AS I THINK ARE ARE
IMMIGRATION PORTFOLIO WHICH
INSURANCE THAT COMMUNITIES WHO
ARE BY DESIGN INCLUDING-
EXCLUDED FROM SOME PROGRAMS HAVE
ACCESS TO LEGAL SERVICES TO
ALLOW THEM TO RECOGNIZE THEIR
STATUS TO BE ABLE TO- BOTH
ACHIEVE GREATER ECONOMIC
STABILITY BUT ALSO ACCESS TO THE
PROGRAM. ALL OF THAT INFORMATION
ALL OF THIS INITIATIVE. IN FIRST
PLANET I THINK THAT- CDSS LITTLE
SERVICES I HAD A LONG OF WORKING
ON EQUITY ISSUES WILL BE TO
GUIDE AND THE DEVELOPMENT OF
THAT OF THE FINAL CLASS I THINK
IS TERRIFIC HERE FOR A LINE- AND
SHARED THAT WILL IN ALSO THE ARE
FAST. WHAT ABLE TO OUR VAST JUST
BUT BUT LOCAL PERSON- I'M MAY
FOCUS THE NUMBER BUT EXAMPLES SO
THAT I CAN THEN SEE HOW WE CAN-
MAKE SUGGESTIONS OR IMPROVEMENTS
OF POSSIBLE BUT ONE TO FOCUS. L.
L. C. SAYS WHERE WE'VE HEARD A
LOT OF THE- IN. PURCHASES OF.
HOW WILL THE EQUITY. PLAN
FOCUSED ON PRO WHERE WE HAVE
DEMONSTRATED DSPARITIES. THAT
WE KNOW ARE EMPIRICALLY WIDE AND
DEEP WHAT SPECIFICALLY CAN WE DO
WITH AND THIS OFFICE TO BE ABLE
TO HELP US OUT WITH THAT. TURN
I'M GONNA I THINK THOSE ARE
EXACTLY THE QUESTIONS WE WANT TO
BE ABLE TO ANSWER THROUGH THIS
PROCESS WE DON'T NECESSARILY
HAVE THOSE ANSWERS JUST YET WE
PLAN TO IS THE- BIG PLANTINGS
THIS PROCESS. CHECK NUMBER WAS
VERY TYPES OF QUESTIONS
PARTICULARLY WHERE WE IDENTIFY
THOSE INEQUITIES- BUT WE'RE
HAPPY TO TAKE THIS QUESTION BACK
AND. PROVIDE ADDITIONAL
INFORMATION AS WELL. THANK FOR
THAT AND I WOULD ADD- UNDER
URBAN RURAL COAST AND INLAND YOU
HAD PROCESS MEASURES AN OUTCOME
MEASURES BUT- OFTENTIMES WE ALSO
HAVE BOTH ENVIRONMENTAL FACTORS
AS WELL AS- DRAMATICALLY
DIFFERENT STATUS. IN OUR
IMMIGRATION AND BELIEVE THAT
IT'S IMPORTANT BOTH
GEOGRAPHICALLY TO COLLECT THIS
INFORMATION BUT JUST TO THINK
BROADLY. ABOUT ALL OF THE
HURDLES THAT SO MANY OF OUR
COMMUNITIES HAVE BEEN ACCESSING
RESOURCES- WITH THAT I WILL
THANKS VERY MUCH THIS PANEL WILL
HOLD THIS ITEM OPEN. WE WILL NOW
MOVE ON TO ISSUE TWO ON THE
OFFICE. BILLION SPONSOR BE. WE
WILL HAVE THREE PRESENTERS ON
THIS PANEL FOR ISSUE TWO. IT
WILL BEGIN WITH LIZ BASSINET
CHIEF RESILIENCE OFFICER WITH
CALIFORNIA HHS AND ACTING
DIRECTOR OF THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA EMERGENCY MEDICAL
SERVICES AUTHORITY. FOLLOWED BY
NINA ALONG WITH THE DEPARTMENT
OF FINANCE ON YOUR PADDOCK WITH
THE L. A. L. LET'S BEGIN WITH
LIZ BASSINET CHIEF RESILIENCE
OFFICER FOR COLLEGE IT JUST. A
GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIR MEMBERS
THANK YOU FOR ALLOWING ME A
CHANCE TO SPEAK WITH YOU ALL
TODAY ARE YOU MENTION MY NAME
BILLS WITH BASS AND I'M THE
CHIEF RESILIENCE OFFICER
CALIFORNIA HEALTH AND HUMAN
SERVICES AGENCY. SO AS YOU'RE
AWARE DISASTERS IN CALIFORNIA
DON'T HAVE A SEASON ANY LONGER
WE'RE VERY MUCH IN THE TWENTY
FOUR SEVEN CYCLE AND THIS CAUSES
DEPARTMENTS TO CONSISTENTLY HAVE
OUR DEPARTMENTS TO HAVE PARALLEL
RATIONS UP FOR MULTIPLE
DISASTERS AT THE SAME TIME SO
WHAT DOES THAT REALLY LOOK LIKE
AN EXAMPLE OF THAT IS OBVIOUSLY.
WE'RE STILL ACTIVELY PURSUING
WILDFIRE RECOVERY OPERATIONS
FROM PREVIOUS YEARS ALL FIFTY
EIGHT COUNTIES CONTINUE TO
RESPOND TO KOBE AS WELL AS
PREPARING FOR AND STARTING TO
RESPOND TO ADDRESS. PREPARING
FOR ANOTHER MAJOR FIRES- AND WE
HAVE THE GEOGRAPHICALLY DEFINED
MISSIONS A WITH AN AGENCY SUCH
AS A BORDER OR OTHER- INCIDENTS
THAT OCCUR. SO CALIFORNIA HEALTH
AND HUMAN SERVICES AGENCY WAS
REAL ORIGINALLY DESIGNED. TO
COORDINATE AND MANAGE THE DAY TO
DAY OPERATIONS OF OR SIGNIFICANT
HEALTH AND HUMAN SERVICES
PROGRAMS. AS YOU ALL KNOW THAT
MISSION ALONE REQUIRES ALL THE
STAFF THAT. HEALTH AND HUMAN
SERVICES. ZERO OVERSEAS AS YOU
KNOW MOST A SMALL OFFICE SO
PRIOR TO TWO THOUSAND SEVENTEEN
WHEN A DISASTER OCCURRED THE
DURATION WAS MUCH SHORTER WE
WORK ON THIS TWENTY FOUR SEVEN.
RESPONSE OPERATION. INDIVIDUALS
WITHIN CALIFORNIA HEALTH AND
HUMAN SERVICES AGENCIES COULD BE
REDIRECTED TEMPORARILY TO GUIDE
OUR DEPARTMENTSAND THEIR
RESPONSE AND RECOVERY REMEMBER.
S. OPERATE. COULD BE READ BACK
FOR- THE POLICY FISCAL PRO
MANAGE OF THE HEALTH IN HUMANS
PROJECT BECAUSE OF THE CYCLE
THAT WE'RE IN AND HAVE MAINTAIN
NOW FOR MULTIPLE YEARS THAT IS
NO LONGER THE CASE AND A FULL
TIME DEDICATED OFFICE AND TEAM
ARE REALLY REQUIRED TO
COORDINATE AND MANAGE OUR
DEPARTMENTS AND OFFICES THROUGH
THE DISASTER CONTINUE ON. SO AS
YOU ARE AWARE WERE REQUESTING I
JUST UNDER TWO POINT SIX MILLION
OF ONGOING GENERAL FUND FOR
THREE YEAR LIMITED TERM BASIS
FOR NINE POSITIONS TO HELP
OVERSEE EACH FIVE CRITICAL
PROGRAMMING AREAS. FOR THIS
OFFICE WITH OUR DEPARTMENT SO IT
WOULD BE PREPAREDNESS RESPONSE
RECOVERY MITIGATION RESILIENCE
AND SPECIAL PROJECTS. I E.
PARTICIPATING IN EQUITY PLANNING
OR CLIMATE CHANGE EXCEPT DROUGHT
AS WE MOVE THROUGH SO REALLY AS
A RESULT DOES REQUIRES THESE
DEDICATED RESOURCES IN ORDER FOR
US TO BE ABLE TO SKATE ALL. TO
THE CONSTANT NATURE OF
EMERGENCIES AND ADDING THIS NEW
STAFF WITHIN THE OFFICE OF
RESPONSE RESILIENCE WITHIN
CALIFORNIA HEALTH AND HUMAN
SERVICES AGENCY ALLOWS US TO
HAVE A MORE APPROPRIATE SPAN OF
CONTROL. AND WORKING WITH ALL OF
OUR- DEPARTMENTS A DISASTER
RESPONSE AND RECOVERY. AS WELL
AS ENSURING THAT. AND ALL OF OUR
POLICIES RESPOND. NOT SO WITH
THAT ALL PUBLIC AND SEE IF THEY
ANY. NINO ONE FOR THE DEPARTMENT
OF FINANCE. NOTHING FURTHER TO
ADD. FROM THE PADDOCK WITH L. L.
C. PADDOCK WITH THE L. A. O. CAL
A TEACHER INDICATE THAT A FOR
THREE YEAR LIMITED TERM FUNDING
FOR THE CREATION OF THIS OFFICE
RATHER THAN PERMANENT FUNDING IN
ORDER TO TAKE A STEP BACK AT THE
END OF THE THREE YEARS AND RE
EVALUATE. THEY ARE. AND I'M-
AND- YOU KNOW WHETHER THE OFFICE
HAS BEEN SUCCESSFUL OR CHANGES
NEED TO BE MADE SO WE WOULD KNOW
HOWEVER THAT THE PROPOSAL LACKS
INFORMATION ABOUT HOW THEIR HOW
THE SORT OF RE EVALUATION OR
EVALUATION WOULD WORK SO FOR
EXAMPLE WILL CAL HHS CONDUCT A
FORMAL ASSESSMENT- AND WHAT
WE'LL CONSIDER IN DETERMINING
WHETHER THE OFFICE HAS BEEN
SUCCESSFUL IN WARRANT WARRANTS
PERMANENT FUNDING- NOR DOES THE
PROPOSAL DESCRIBE HOW KELLY
TEACHERS WOULD INVOLVE THE
LEGISLATURE IN MAKING THAT
DETERMINATION SO WE SUBJECT
ASKING FOR MORE INFORMATION.
ABOUT THIS- FINALLY WE NOTE
THERE'S NO COME TRAILER BILL
LANGUAGE FOR THIS PROPOSAL- THIS
WILL OBVIOUSLY BE IMPORTANT FOR
IRONING OUT THE DETAILS AND
LAYING OUT THE EXPECTATIONS FOR
THE OFFICE AND WE SUGGEST THAT
YOU ASK THE ADMINISTRATION FOR
SUCH LANGUAGES SOON AS- FEASIBLE
. THANK YOU I WILL BRING IT UP
TO THE DIESS I WILL- TURNED TO
MIST BASSINET IF I CAN- I'M
QUITE- IMPRESSED WITH THIS
PROPOSAL AND THINK IT'S
IMPORTANT FOR US TO PREPARE FOR
AN EMERGENCY WHEN WE ARE NOT IN
ONE. AND THUS I BELIEVE IT'S
IMPORTANT FOR US TO HAVE
APPROPRIATE STAFF WHO ARE
DEDICATED TO THE RESILIENCE AND
RESPONSE WHICH WILL BE
NECESSARY. BUT I'D LIKE TO ASK
WHY IT'S ONLY LIMITED TERM FOR
THESE THREE YEAR PERIOD AS WELL
AS WHAT OUTCOMES- WE ARE
ANTICIPATING OR HOW WE WILL
MEASURE SUCCESS WITHIN THIS NEW
OFFICE HOPING YOU CAN COMMENT ON
THAT. YES ABSOLUTELY SO FOR THE
FIRST PIECE OF BEING- AS WAS.
INDICATED IT'S IMPORTANT FOR US
TO TAKE A STEP BACK AND KIND OF
DO THIS FORMAL ASSESSMENT AT THE
END OF THE THREE YEARS TO
ENSURE. THAT WHAT WE'RE SETTING
UP THE INFRASTRUCTURE THAT WE'RE
PUTTING IN PLACE HAS BEEN
SUCCESSFUL THAT WE'RE GETTING
THE RIGHT RESOURCES TO THE RIGHT
PLACE AT THE RIGHT TIME. AND
THAT OUR OVER ARCHING POLICY IS-
DAUGHTER BEING DEVELOPED AS DATA
COMES IN FROM ALL OF THESE
DIFFERENT DEPARTMENTS. THAT
ACTUALLY. DOES FOR SUBSEQUENT
RESPONSES HAD. A GOOD IMPACT.
YOU KNOW A GREAT EXAMPLE OF THIS
OBVIOUSLY IS WITH DROUGHT. TOP
OF EVERYONE'S MIND AND SO REALLY
AN ASSESSMENT AS EVEN RIGHT NOW
YOU KNOW WE'VE CREATED OUR
DROUGHT ACTION PLAN AS A OUT OF
AGENCIES ARE CROSSCUTTING
ARGUMENTS THAT ALL OF THE
DEPARTMENTS KNOW. THE DIFFERENCE
IS THE DROUGHT HOW GOING TO BE
RESPONDING AND HOW ARE DIFFERENT
PROGRAM. AND DIFFERENT WORK EACH
OTHER. WHETHER THAT BE LOOKING
UP THE NUMBER OF CALIBRATION CAL
WORKS APPLE CANCER THE NUMBER OF
INDIVIDUALS COVERED BY HEALTH
CARE PLANS. SUCH YOUR WORK
PURCHASE IN THAT. BEING ABLE TO.
DATA OF THE HIGH LEVEL. FOR
POLICY AND THEN SHARE IT BACK
DOWN THE ROAD APART IN ORDER TO
DRIVE TO RESPONSE I THINK IT'S-
IS. AND YOU HAVE MEANT IN YOUR
REAL. THAT IT WAS A FORMER US.
HAVE WE- HAVE WE FORMALIZE THAT
AS WELL AS- I WOULD LIKE TO ASK
THE ADMINISTRATION TO PLEASE
PROVIDE THE TRAILER BILL
LANGUAGE FOR THE ESTABLISHMENT
OF THIS NEW OFFICE BEFORE OR- AT
THE TIME OF MAY REVISE AND JUST
WANTS TO MAKE SURE THAT THE
ADMINISTRATION IS AMENABLE TO
THAT. YES WE RECEIVE THAT
FEEDBACK AND ARE WORKING ON
TRAILER BILL LANGUAGE- IN TERMS
OF THE FORMALITY OF THE
ASSESSMENT I THINK THERE ARE
STILL METRICS OF SUCCESS THAT
NEED TO BE DETERMINED BUT
CERTAINLY WITHIN THE BUDGET
CHANGE PROPOSAL ITSELF. THERE
ARE VERY SPECIFIC METRICS
ATTACHED TO DAYS- BETTER
MILESTONES THAT ARE KEY FOR US
TO MEET WITH THE CREATION OF
THIS NEW OFFICE AND THEN VERY
MUCH. IF WE MET THIS METRIC WHAT
DID THAT MEAN FOR THE PATIENT OR
THE WHOLE OF PERSON ON THE
GROUND AND REALLY BE ABLE TO
DELINEATE THOSE THINGS OUT. WITH
THAT I'D LIKE TO THANK VERY MUCH
THIS PANEL WE WILL HOLD FOR THIS
ITEM OPEN AND WE WILL NOW MOVE
ON TO ISSUE THREE WHICH IS ON
THE OFFICE OF AGENCY INFORMATION
OFFICER. AND THE OFFICE OF
SYSTEMS INTEGRATION ENTERPRISE
CAPABILITIES BCP. WE WILL HAVE
FOR PRESENT. AND THIS ISSUE FOR
PANEL THREE BEGINNING WITH ADAM
DONDERO. DEPUTY SECRETARY AND
AGENCY CHIEF INFORMATION OFFICER
WITH CAL HHS. FOLLOWED BY DEANNA
WORDEN DEPUTY AGENCY INFORMATION
OFFICER WITH CALLIE TRADE. NINA
HUANG WITH DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE
AND BRIAN METZGER WITH THE L. A.
L. LET'S BEGIN WITH ADAM DONDERO
PLEASE BEGIN. THANK YOU GET YOUR
CHAIR MEMBERS OPERATIONS
OPPORTUNITY TO REPRESENT THIS
PROPOSAL AROUND BRINGING MORE
ENTERPRISE APPROACH TO
INFORMATION TECHNOLOGY APLIKASI
CAN THINK AND I'M GOING TO HAND
IT OVER TO OUR DEPUTY ALBION ONE
. THANK YOU ADAM I'M AFRAID I
HAD A CAMERA FAILURE MADE YOU
CAN KICK US OFF WHILE I TRY TO
GET THAT BACK WORKING. NOT A
PROBLEM YOU KNOW WHEN YOU'RE
READY. SO DID YOU SEE IN THE
PROPOSAL WERE PROPOSED BEING
RESOURCES THAT FOR THE FIRST
TIME ALLOW CALIFORNIA HEALTH AND
HUMAN SERVICES AGENCY. TO BRING
THAT ENTERPRISE APPROACH TO THE
WAY THAT WE CAN DAHLE
INFLAMMATION TECHNOLOGY. THE
IDEA HERE IS THAT WITH MY OFFICE
WE'VE BEEN TYPICALLY FOCUS ON.
PROJECT OVERSIGHT WITH SMALL
ABILITY TO DO OTHER WORK IN THE
OFFICE OF SYSTEMS INTEGRATION
ATTEMPTS BUT SPECIFICALLY
FOCUSED. ON DOING THE LARGE
SCALE COMPLEX PROJECT THE
BUSINESS. PORTFOLIO BUT IN OUR
OFFICE TO GATHER. IS TO BREAK
OUT OF THE SILOS IN THE PRODUCT
AND OFFICES. I THEIR- NEEDS
WITHOUT THAT SCOPE OF WHAT'S
GOING ON ACROSS THE AGENCY AND
BEING ABLE TO WRITE. MEANS BY
WHICH TO SHARE EXPERTISE SHARE
RESOURCES GIVEN SHARE SYSTEMS. A
LOT OF OPPORTUNITIES THERE. APAN
THEIR DM. AND SO HERE IS. WELL
NOT A PROBLEM. THE IDEA IS THAT
AT THE AGENCY LEVEL WE NEED
RESOURCES WHO ARE NOT FOCUSED ON
INDIVIDUAL PROJECTS AND YOU'VE
SEEN WHAT MANY ID PROPOSAL BUT
THE PROMPTER THAT SUBCOMMITTEE.
THEY ARE SO. TO PARTICULAR PART
. MANY OF THE ENTERPRISE. YOU'RE
LOOKING PROJECT TEMPLE VOLUME.
LOOKING AT TECHNOLOGY. LOOKING
AT SECURITY THAT ALLOW US TO
START LOOKING AT THINGS ACROSS
THE ENTIRETY OFTHE AGENCY NOT A
LOT OF BENEFITS TO GO TO THAT.
SPECIFICALLY BENEFITS TO THE
PUBLIC IN TERMS OF THE SERVICES
WERE ABLE TO PROVIDE. THE AND
YOU WANT TO JUMP ON. SHURIKENS
TO THE ENTERPRISE PORTFOLIO
MANAGEMENT PROGRAM THAT WE PLAN
TO STAND UP AND THIS WILL GIVE
US A MUCH MORE COMPREHENSIVE
UNDERSTANDING OF OUR EXISTING
AND OUR PLANNED IT ASSETS
THOUGH. HAVING THAT AGENCY WIDE
UNDERSTANDING WILL INFORM OUR
PLANNING AND OUR PRIORITIZATION
IN THE INVESTMENTS THAT WE BEAT
THAT WE DECIDE TO MAKE IT. AS AN
ARE INTERNET. WORKING ON THE
ENTERPRISE PORTFOLIO MANAGEMENT
PROGRAM WILL ALSO INCLUDE SOME
DATA DRIVEN DECISION MAKING
PROCESSES THAT ARE NEEDED TO
MAKE THOSE KEY DECISIONS. AND
WILL IDENTIFY POTENTIAL
OPPORTUNITIES TO REUSE OUR
EXISTING SOLUTIONS AND THIS IS A
GREAT WAY TO LEVERAGE OUR PRIOR.
INVESTMENTS AND TO REDUCE THE
RISK ASSOCIATED WITH SUPPORTING
NEW PROGRAMS FROM SIMILAR
CAPABILITIES. FINALLY IT WILL
INFORM THE TO THE- OF SOLUTIONS
THAT REALLY INTEGRATE AND WORK
TOGETHER AS ADAM TALKED ABOUT
THIS CROSS AGENCY PERSPECTIVE IS
VERY IMPORTANT. AS IT SUPPORTS-OUR AGENCIES PRIORITIES AND MORE
IMPORTANTLY ALLOWS FOR THAT DATA
SHARING THAT HELPS US INFORM THE
POLICY THE PROGRAM DESIGN. I
REALLY JUST BETTER MEET THE
NEEDS OF THE POPULATION THAT WE
THAT WE SERVE. ADAM ALSO
MENTIONED A CENTER OF EXCELLENCE
WE DO PROPOSED TO PUT TOGETHER A
SMALL CENTER OF EXCELLENCE THAT
CAN HELP ACCELERATE IN AND
IMPROVE THE DELIVERY IN THE
QUALITY OF THE I. T. SOLUTIONS.
THIS IS A COUPLE OF AREAS FIRST
OF. HHS HELPING HUMANS SPECIFIC
TOOLS I TEMPLATES PLANNING
GUIDANCE THAT ARE BASED ON
PROVEN PRACTICES BUT OF COURSE
THE LINE WITH THE CDT
REQUIREMENTS BUT TAKE INTO
ACCOUNT THE UNIQUE. PROGRAMMATIC
ASPECTS OF THE THAT WE HAVE.
THIS APPOINTMENT FOUNDATION FOR
THE HIGHER QUALITY MORE
EFFICIENT PLANNING AND THE
SPEED. TO DELIVERY IF THOSE
BUSINESS BENEFITS IN THE
BUSINESS CAPABILITIES THAT ARE
DEPARTMENTS VERY MUCH NEAT. OUR
RESOURCES WILL DEVELOP THESE
MAINTAIN THEM AND UPDATE THEM AS
WE LEARN MORE AS WE IDENTIFY NEW
STRATEGIES THAT WILL REDUCE THE
TIME COST AND RISK AND WILL WORK
DIRECTLY WITH A PARTNER. THE USE
THESE. THIS INCREASE SOUTH A
WELL WILL REDUCE THE RELY ON
VENDORS TO HELP US PLAN. OUR
SOLUTIONS AND IT WE FIND THAT
pEMPLOYEES SKILLS AND RETENTION
WHICH IS CRITICAL RIGHT NOW FOR
THE TEAMS THAT WE HAVE. AS PART
OF THIS CENTER OF EXCELLENCE
WILL ALSO HAVE A SMALL SET OF
HIGHLY EXPERIENCED TECHNOLOGIST
IT'S VERY DIFFICULT TO GET SOME
OF THESE KEY SKILLS IN THE
MARKET TODAY. I AM THESE
TECHNOLOGISTS CAN HELP ITS
JUMPSTART AND AUGMENT THE TEAMS
TO MAKE SURE THAT THE EARLY
PLANNING WORK IN ONGOING
PLANNING WORK RELATED TO THINGS
LIKE ENTERPRISE ARCHITECTURE.
DATA ARCHITECTURE SOLUTION
INTEGRATION CYBER SECURITY TO
MAKE SURE DEPARTMENT HAVE THE
SKILL SETS AT THE READY FOR THEM
AS THEY EMBARK ON THE SOLUTIONS.
THIS WILL BE A PARTICULAR
BENEFIT- SMALLER DEPARTMENTS BUT
ALSO OUR LARGE APARTMENTS CAN
BENEFIT FROM THIS AND THE ACCESS
THESE THREE. SCRIPT BECAUSE
WITHOUT WE DON'T LET OUR PRIDE
SINCE WE END UP SOLUTIONS AND
WILLING. IN THIS KEY AREAS. SO
I'M- THIS PROPOSAL IS GOING TO
HELP US DO A FEW THINGS SPEND
THE LIMITED RESOURCES WHERE
THEY'RE MOST NEEDED TO MANAGE
BUILDING SUPPORTER ID EFFORTS
MORE HOLISTICALLY DELIVER THE
BENEFIT OF I. T. MORE QUICKLY
AND AT A LOWER COST ALLOWING HER
PROGRAMS TO FOCUS ON THE
RESOURCES THAT HELP PEOPLE
DIRECTLY AND DRIVE SOLUTIONS
THAT ARE GOING TO SUPPORT OUR
AGENCY AND THE ADMINISTRATION'S
PRIORITIES FOR HELPING THE
CALIFORNIANS NEED. VERY GRATEFUL
FOR YOUR GENERATION APOLOGIZE
FOR THE CAMERA ISSUES AND AM
HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS
YOU MIGHT HAVE. THANK YOU WE
WILL MEXICO TO THE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE. THE CURRENT FINANCING
HUNG NOTHING FURTHER AT. THANK
YOU PRIME MINISTER WITH THE L.
L. PRIME MINISTER ALAIA WE
REVIEWED THIS PROPOSAL HAVE NO
CONCERNS. THANK YOU- BRING IT UP
TO THE DENTIST TO SEE IF ANY
MEMBERS HAVE QUESTIONS I WILL
BEGIN WITH. GROWER MISS HORTON
IF I CAN I'M I'M HOPING THAT YOU
CAN. I HEARD THAT YOU'RE WORKING
ON MORE HOLISTIC ENTERPRISE
SOLUTIONS THAT WILL BOTH LOWER
COST AND DRIVE SOLUTIONS. INTO
OUR- SYSTEMS BUT I'M HOPING THAT
YOU CAN GIVE US SOME SPECIFIC
OUTCOMES FOR CLIENTS THAT CAN BE
EXPECTED AS A RESULT OF THIS
WORK. CAN YOU GIVE US A FEW
EXAMPLES. WE'LL SEE. AS A RESULT
OF THIS FUNDING. I CAN CERTAINLY
GIVE YOU A FEW EXAMPLES OF A
HIGH LEVEL AND THEN I CAN
PROVIDE YOU WITH A COUPLE THAT
IF IN PLACE WE COULD DELIVER
THEM THE RELATED BENEFITS SO I
MENTIONED THAT THE PROPOSAL
SUPPORT MORE TIMELY DELIVERY-
AND THAT THEY'LL MAKE BEST USE.
AND WILL. RIGHT THE AREAS THAT I
REALLY WANT TO FOCUS ON FOR US
AT THE AGENCY LEVEL IS THE
EXPANSION OF THE BEHAVIORAL
HEALTH AND OTHER PROGRAMS THAT
ARE SUPPORTING HOLISTIC CARE FOR
MEDICARE OPULATION THIS WORK
REALLY EXTENDS BEYOND THE WORK
BEING DONE WITHIN THE DEPARTMENT
OF HEALTH CARE SERVICES BECAUSE
MANY OF THE SERVICES AND SYSTEMS
ARE REQUIRED TO INFORM CENTER
APPROACH TO AND TO WELL BEING
INCLUDING BEHAVIORAL. AND RESIDE
IN APARTMENTS ULTIMATELY AL
INTEGRATE WITH THE MEDICAL
SYSTEMS AND WITH OTHER SYSTEMS
IN OUR DEPARTMENT HAVING THIS
ENTERPRISE PORTFOLIO MANAGEMENT
YOU ALLOWS US TO UNDERSTAND AND
LOOK AT ALL OF THIS DEPENDENCIES
INTER DEPENDENCIES AND RIGHT
SURE THAT WERE INFORMING THOSE
MOTIONS EARLY BECAUSE WE DON'T
WE END UP WITH A SILENT SOLUTION
THAT THEN REQUIRES REDEVELOPMENT
ADDITIONAL DOLLARS AND JUST
DOESN'T LET US SHARE THE DATA
THAT WE NEED TO SHARE. IT FEELS
LIKE AN INDIRECT. IMPACT AT THE
END OF THE DAY IT DOESN'T GET US
ORDER TO. WHAT WE NEED OR AGENCY
WHAT WE NEED TO ACTUALLY SIR
CALIFORNIANS DIFFICULT TO
QUANTIFY THAT- IN TERMS OF
PROVIDING THOSE AUGMENTED
RESOURCES DEPARTMENT OF SOCIAL
SERVICES HAS TAKEN ON A
TREMENDOUS PROGRAMMATIC GROWTH.
AND THEY HAVE TO BUILD THE I. T.
SOLUTIONS TO SUPPORT THERE'S
REALLY NO OPTION BUT GETTING
RESOURCES RECREATED AND
ONBOARDED QUICKLY ENOUGH EVEN IN
THOSE IT ESPECIALLY THOSE KEY
SKILLS AT. IT'S VERY DIFFICULT
AND SO THROUGH THE SEPARATE I
MENTIONED JUMPSTARTING IN
AUGMENTING PROGRESS OF PROJECTS
THIS CAN IN THIS HAS THIS DIRECT
IMPACT. OF SPEECH. EVERY OF THE
PROJECT WE DON'T HAVE THE
DELAYS. IN GETTING THE BILL
ABOUT OUT BY T. OF BRING.
ACTUALLY PROVIDING SERVICES TO
CALIFORNIANS SINGER WE HAVE
THESE PROGRAMS BUT IF WE CAN'T
SUPPORT THEM WITH TECHNOLOGY IN
A TIMELY MANNER WE CAN'T DELIVER
THAT BUSINESS VALUE. I'M IN I
THINK YOU KNOW A GOOD EXAMPLE
TWO OF THE WORK THAT OUR SITE IS
ALREADY DOING THAT LEANS TOWARDS
THIS IS THE ARE. YOU POSTING
STEP WITHIN THE EMERGENCY
MEDICAL SERVICES AUTHORITY M.
IT'S A VERY LARGE EFFORT
ASSIGNED TO AN ORGANIZATION WITH
LIMITED PRIOR EXPERIENCE AND
SKILL RESOURCES SENATE WOULD
HAVE REQUIRED CONSIDERABLE AND
CHALLENGE RECRUITING AND
TRAINING EFFORTS. IF I WERE
SIGNED AND NOT BEEN ABLE TO
AUGMENT THAT. I'M WE HAVE OTHER
DEPARTMENTS EARLY AND SOME
THINGS. AGING ALSO SMALLER A
MASSIVE YOU'RE TAKING WITH EIGHT
MASTER H. SO. WE ANTICIPATE THAT
THIS WE- WILL HELP ACCELERATE
THIS BUSINESS BENEFITS AND GET
SERVICES INTO THE HANDS OF OUR
POPULATION CENTER. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH FOR THAT RESPONSE- I
THOUGHT IT WAS VERY HELPFUL TO
BRING IN SILOS AS IT REALLY
SEEMS THEY ARE BREAKING DOWN
MANY OF THOSE SILOS. WITH
CREATING AND HAVING. AN
ENTERPRISE SOLUTION AND HAVING
THE VANTAGE POINT THAT YOU DO.
BRING UP THE POST IS CLOSE TO MY
OFFICE AS WE WERE VERY INVOLVED
ENSURING- THE THIS WAS INCLUDE
INTO LAST YEAR'S BUDGET. AND
BELIEVE IT'S IMPORTANT FOR US TO
BREAK THOSE SILOS SO WE CAN
BETTER SERVE OUR COMMUNITY
MEMBERS AND- NOW WOULD LIKE TO
TRANSITION IF I CAN YOU SAID IT
WAS GOING TO BE DIFFICULT TO
QUANTIFY AND- THIS IS ALL. JUST
LET. TO MAKE SURE THERE WERE.
BUILDING SYSTEMS THAT WILL
MEASURE THE EFFECTIVENESS AND
SUCCESS OF. THIS INITIATIVE
SPECIFICALLY. SO I'D LIKE TO ASK
HOW WE MAKE QUANTIFY AS WELL AS
ON WHAT TIME BASIS WILL THIS
OCCUR SO THAT WE CAN HAVE SOME
ACCOUNTABILITY WITH THE
LEGISLATURE. YEAH ABSOLUTELY AND
I'LL TURN THAT OVER TO YOU GIVEN
OUR DISCUSSIONS. ABSOLUTELY YEAH
AND IT STOP WHEN YOU'RE SETTING
UP THE FOUNDATIONS FOR A
PROJECT- TO PUT THOSE METRICS IN
PLACE I THINK THAT AS WE LOOK AT
WHAT WE HOPE TO ACHIEVE OVER THE
NEXT ONE TO TWO YEARS. WHEN YOU
ASK IN TERMS OF CRIME I
UNDERSTAND THAT THANKS. FOR
TALKING ABOUT. JENNIFER THESE
SERVICES THE- PROVIDED AN
ENTERPRISE LEVEL THE DEPARTMENT
NEED LIKE A PENSION WOULD BE
COULD COUNT ON A- LOOK AT.
PROJECT INTAKE IT OUT PUT THE
WOE WE CALL BY DOES THE- IN THE
FIELD SERVICE. AND BEING ABLE TO
RIDE. WHAT SKILLS. AND WE PUT IN
PLACE IN THE BANNER BACK ONCE
WHERE WE'VE BEEN ABLE TO PROVIDE
THOSE RESOURCES AND ALIGN IN
NUMBER THE NEED. ALONG WITH ANY
GAPS THAT WE IDENTIFY IN TERMS
OF ADDITIONAL NEEDS WHERE WE
COULD DO TAKE. THIS MORE
ENTERPRISE APPROACH TO PROVIDE
IT. WILL BE ABLE TO DOCUMENT
THOSE. ADDITIONALLY IN TERMS OF
WHAT ADIANTUM. THEN THE
ENTERPRISE PORTFOLIO MANAGEMENT
. WE'LL BE LOOKING AT FUNCTION
AT THE DEPARTMENT. I MEAN MEANT
THAT THEY- TO ESTABLISH THAT THE
OPPORTUNITY FOR WE USE SHARED.
AB AND AGENCIES ENTERPRISE
ARCHITECTURE APPROACH THAT
ALLOWS US TO IDENTIFY THOSE
OPPORTUNITIES EVEN BEFORE
PROPOSAL MADE WELL WE CAN START
GETTING IN FRONT OF THOSE AND SO
I THINK THAT'S WHERE YOU'LL
START TO SEE WHAT WE CAN BE
IDENTIFIED IN PHOTOS THAT YOU I
MEAN FOR ONE STATE I'M NOT
ENTERPRISE APPROACH YOUR
JOURNALISM MODEL. WE WANT TO LET
SOMETHING. THAT THREE AGAINST TO
FEL. METRICS A BIT OF A STRONG
BUT OUTCOME OF BEATRIZ. FOR
THANK YOU FOR THAT- WITH THAT I
WILL THANK VERY MUCH THIS PANEL
WILL HOLD THIS ITEM OPEN AND WE
WILL NOW MOVE ON TO THE
DEPARTMENT. OF DEVELOPMENTAL
SERVICES PROPOSAL ON THE
DISCUSSION AGENDA. WE ARE NOW ON
ISSUE FOR ON THE DIVISION OF
COMMUNITY ASSISTANCE AND
RESOLUTION PCP. WITH TRAILER
BILL LANGUAGE WE WILL HAVE FOUR
PRESENTERS ON THIS PANEL
BEGINNING WITH DIRECTOR NANCY
PARCHMENT DEPARTMENT OF
DEVELOPMENTAL SERVICES WHO.
THANKFULLY IS HERE PERSON PETE
SERVING THIRTY CHIEF DEPUTY
DIRECTOR OF DATA AND ANALYTICS
WITH DDS. AND CHRISTOPHER ADENI
ALL WITH DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE
AND TANYA ADEQUATE THE- LET'S
BEGIN WITH DIRECTOR. PLEASE BE
WHEN YOU ARE READY THANK YOU DR
RANDY AND- THE COMMITTEES TIME
TODAY TO BE ABLE TO PRESENT TO
YOU. THE PROPOSAL THAT WE HAVE-
AS THE AGENDA CORRECTLY NOTES-
THAT WE ARE PROPOSING A DIVISION
OF COMMUNITY ASSISTANCE AND
RESOLUTIONS. I'M IN THIS
PROPOSAL WE ARE REQUESTING FOUR
POINT FOUR MILLION DOLLARS WITH
TWENTY PERMANENT POSITIONS THAT
WOULD BE ASSOCIATED WITH THAT.
THIS ALSO INCLUDES- THE FUNDING
THAT WOULD BE WITH THE AGREEMENT
AND DEPARTMENT OF GENERAL
SERVICES. SO AS WE KNOW THE BEST
WAY THAT WE CAN SUPPORT THE
INDIVIDUALS THAT WE SERVE AND
OUR DEVELOPMENTAL SERVICES
SYSTEM THROUGHOUT THEIR LIFE. IS
REALLY ENGAGING WITH THEM
LISTENING TO WHAT THEIR ISSUES
ARE WHAT THEIR CONCERNS ARE WHAT
THE BARRIERS ARE. AND WE'VE BEEN
ABLE TO DO THAT FOR SO MANY
DIFFERENT INITIATIVES. AND THIS
IS ONE THAT WE'VE REALLY BEEN
ABLE TO TAKE HAND IN HAND WITH
OUR COMMUNITY OF OVER THE LAST
YEAR TO UNDERSTAND THE
CHALLENGES THAT WE HAVE. SO WITH
THIS WE HAVE AN OPPORTUNITY TO
REALLY UNDERSTAND AND IMPROVE
THE COMMUNICATE AND ADDRESS
THESE BARRIERS. SO TO IMPROVE
THE EXPERIENCE OF THOSE THAT WE
SERVE. THE NEW DIVISION WOULD
ENABLE DDS TO CENTRALIZE THE
CATHOLIC COMPLAINTS. AND
RESOLUTIONS THAT WE CAN TIED TO
THOSE COMPLAINTS AND THEN
EMBRACING THE COLD LINGUISTICS
SENSITIVITIES HAVE TRANSPARENCY.
AND IN DOWN TREND THAT WE ARE
SEEING IN OUR SYSTEM AND TO BE
ABLE TO DEVELOP POLICIES TO
IMPROVE THOSE AS- THIS FOR. HAS
TENTATIVE WOULD HAVE KEY COULD.
THE FIRST IS- IMPROVING THE
MANAGEMENT OF OUR COMMUNITY
COMPLAINTS- COMPLAINTS THAT ARE.
REGARDING TO NILE CLIENT RIGHT-
REFORMING OUR APPEALS AND OUR
STATE HEARING PROCESS. SECOND
WOULD BE ENHANCING THE
DEPARTMENT'S RESOURCES FOR
QUALITY ASSURANCE AND MEASURES.
THIS WOULD BE THE AREA THAT WE
WOULD BE ABLE TO TIE. ALSO TO BE
QUALITY INCENTIVE PROGRAM. AND
BEING ABLE TO UNDERSTAND
STATEWIDE AND WITHIN EACH
REGIONAL CENTER SOME OF THOSE
ISSUES THAT WE HAVE AS FAR AS
MOVING TOWARDS THE COMMUNITY
OUTCOMES. ALSO FOCUSING EFFORTS
ON RISK MANAGEMENT IN SUPPORT OF
CRITICAL INITIATIVES WE DO TRACK
SPECIAL INCIDENT REPORTS WE HAVE
QUITE A BIT OF INFORMATION THAT
WE ARE ABLE TO DO. BUT WE REALLY
DON'T HAVE A DESIGNATED AREA IN
WHICH WERE ABLE TO UNDERSTAND
THOSE ISSUES UNDERSTAND THE
TRENDS AND DEVELOP RISK
MANAGEMENT AND- PLANS TO BE ABLE
TO MITIGATE THOSE RISKS. LASTLY
IS CREATING OMBUDSPERSON OFFICE
THAT WOULD BE AVAILABLE
STATEWIDE. SO WE'D LIKE TO THANK
OUR SELF ADVOCATES AND FAMILIES
THAT HAVE SHARED THE PERSONAL
STORIES TO UNDERSTAND THE
ISSUES. AND BE ABLE TO HELP US-
REALLY DESIGN A COMPREHENSIVE
REFORM OF OUR FAIR HEARING
PROCESS ALSO WANT TO THANK HER
COLLEAGUES OVER AT TGS THE
DIRECTOR AND HER STAFF HAVE BEEN
REMARKS. THINKING THIS. AND THEN
ALSO THE REGIONAL CENTER AND
OTHERS THAT HAVE- GIVEN SOME
THOUGHT TO HOW WE CAN BEST SERVE
OUR INDIVIDUALS. IT'S ALL TURN
IT OVER TO MY COLLEAGUE MISTER
SHIVIKA. MISTER CHAIRMAN BURST
THANKS FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO BE
HERE AND TALK ABOUT THIS
PROPOSAL IS THE DIRECTOR COVERED
THIS IS PRETTY CENTRAL TO
EVERYTHING WE'RE DOING FOR THE
CONSUMERS AND TRYING TO SHIFT
OUR SYSTEM TO. OUTCOME FOCUSED.
HAPPY TO RESPOND TO THE
QUESTIONS IN THE AGENDA
QUESTIONS ONE THREE AND FOUR-
ALL RELATE TO FAIR HEARING SO IF
IT'S OKAY I'LL COVER THOSE FIRST
AND THEN JUMP BACK TO NUMBER
TWO. OF THE FIRST PART OF THE
FIRST QUESTION ASKS ABOUT THE
PROCESS THAT THE DEPARTMENT WENT
THROUGH. APPRECIATE THE THOROUGH
RIGHT UP IN THE AGENDA N THIS
TOPIC STARTING ON PAGE FIFTEEN
AND FIRST FULL PARAGRAPH
DESCRIBES THAT A LITTLE BIT. BUT
IT BUT IN SOME MORE DETAIL WE
DID IS STARTING IN APRIL LAST
YEAR CONVENE SIX DIFFERENT FOCUS
GROUPS- WITH VARIOUS
STAKEHOLDER. GROUPS WE- HE
EQUITABLE ACCESS AND EQUITY
CBO'S TWO DIFFERENT GROUPS- WITH
FAMILY MEMBERS SELF ADVOCATES
AND ADVOCACY ORGANIZATIONS
INCLUDING THE STATE COUNCIL WE
MET WITH FAMILY RESOURCE CENTERS
AND WE ABOUT WITH REGIONAL
CENTERS ON THEIR EXECUTIVE
DIRECTORS- AND THEY'RE FAIR
HEARING A COORDINATORS- WE ALSO
MET SEPARATELY WITH SEVERAL
DIFFERENT ADVOCACY ORGANIZATIONS
AS WELL OUTSIDE OF THOSE.
ADDITIONALLY ON OCTTWENTY
TWENTY ONE- WE- SURVEYED- ALL
OVER SIXTEEN HUNDRED PEOPLE WHO
EXPERIENCE THE HEARINGS PROCESS
IN THE LAST THREE YEARS- AND-
CONVENED AND- TWO SEPARATE
FOLLOW UP FOCUS GROUPS WITH THEM
AS WELL BASED ON THEIR INTEREST
AND WILLINGNESS TO SHARE THEIR
EXPERIENCES WITH US. AND THOSE
ARE REALLY THAT- THE SOURCES-
ADDITIONALLY- WE RECEIVED A
REPORT DONE BY ADVOCATES ABOUT
THE HEARING PROCESS THEY THEY
WROTE THEIR OWN INDEPENDENT
REPORT AND WENT THROUGH THAT
WITH US. SO WE HAD MULTIPLE
SOURCES BEEN. UP TO THE UPPER
DATES TO THE OVERALL APPEALS
PROCESS NOT JUST THE HEARINGS
THEMSELVES THAT CONTAINER APRIL
ONE PROPOSAL. ON THE AGENDA IN
THE SECOND HALF OF THAT QUESTION
ASKED WHY WE CHOSE DGS- AS AS MY
DIRECTOR ALLUDED TO WE HAVE A
COMMITMENT FROM THE DIRECTOR OF
DG ASSET AND HER TEAM. BUT TO
GET TO PARTNER WITH US- TO
PROVIDE A DE DETAIL ABOUT THAT-
THEY ARE. PROVIDE THESE HEARING
THROUGH ITS OFF OF
ADMINISTRATIVE HEARINGS THAT'S
BEEN A LONG STANDING
RELATIONSHIP WITH THEM FOR MANY
YEARS- AND THEY HAVE COMMITTED
TO- TO PARTNER WITH US TO MAKE
THIS EXPERIENCE. BETTER FOR
FAMILIES- WHO ARE GOING THROUGH
THIS PROCESS AND THE INDIVIDUALS
THAT WE SERVE OF COURSE- MET
THERE'S OBVIOUSLY EXPERTISE IN
CONDUCTING HEARINGS IN MANY
PLACES- IN THE ADMINISTRATION.
BOTH DEPARTMENT OF GENERAL
SERVICES AND SOCIAL SERVICES
PROVIDED INPUT TO OUR TRAILER
BILL PROPOSAL- AND YOU SEE THAT
REFLECTED THERE ARE A NUMBER OF
CASES SO- YOU KNOW AS A WHOLE
OVERALL THE ADMINISTRATION IS
COMMITTED TO MAKING THIS A
BETTER PLACE AND- YOU KNOW.
FRANKLY DANGERS OF THE MAGNITUDE
PROPOSING COULD NOT HAPPEN JULY
ONE ANYWAY AND WE THINK IT'S
RIGHT TO GO AHEAD AND START
WHERE THEY ARE AND TO APPRECIATE
THE COMMITMENT OF THE DGS TO
PARTNER WITH US. TO MAKE THOSE
THINGS A REALITY. THANK YOU
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE.
CHRISTOPHER O'NEILL DEPARTMENT
OF FINANCE NOTHING FURTHER ADAMS
ITEMS AFTER THANK YOU SUNNY
PADDOCK WITH THE L. L. S. SENATE
PETTICOAT THE L. A- WE'VE
REVIEWED THE PROPOSAL IN THE
ASSOCIATED TRAILER BILL
LANGUAGE- THE PROPOSAL REALLY
DOES TRY TO IDENTIFY AND ADDRESS
SOME OF THE KEY CHALLENGES AND
PROBLEMS. IN THE DISPUTE
RESOLUTION PROCESS- IMMEDIATELY
WE DO NOT RAISE ANY CONCERNS BUT
WILL CONTINUE TO GO OVER THE
DETAILS AND COMMUNICATE WITH
SUBCOMMITTEE STAFF- ON FURTHER
COMMENTS THANK YOU THANK YOU I
WILL BRING IT UP TO THE DENTIST
REMEMBERS QUESTIONS I WILL KEEP
IT HERE. WE HEARD ABOUT AN
INDEPENDENT REPORT FROM
STAKEHOLDERS OPENED OF FOLLOW UP
WITH A LITTLE MORE DETAIL IF I
CAN BUT WANTED TO SEE IF YOU
COULD SUMMARIZE THEIR REACTION
TO THE DDS HEARINGS THUS FAR
FROM THE STAKEHOLDER COMMUNITY
HOWEVER THEY- GAUGE WHAT'S IN
THERE AND BUT LOOK FOR ALL OF
US. SURE AND YOU'RE ASKING ABOUT
THE REACTION TO PUZZLE YEP- OF
THE WE'VE HAD SEVERAL WE'VE HAD
PRIVATE BREEZED AND I LEAVING
FOR THAT A LARGELY THEY SEEM
THINGS THAT LIKE IT AND THEY
SOME- WHERE. TURN FRANK AND-
WE'VE TRIED TO DEFINE UNDER OF
OUR TO WHAT THEY'LL WE MEANS-
AND WE'VE- A PAST TO CONTINUE
DIALOGUE WITH US- AND WE'VE
SOLICITED- KIND OF LINE ITEM AT
ITS IF YOU WILL AND THEMATIC
THINGS THAT THEY'VE ALREADY TOLD
US- FOR CONSIDERATION A ONE OF
THE BIG MISSING THINGS IN OUR
PROPOSAL AT THE MOMENT THAT WE
KNOW NEEDS TO BE ADDED AND
EXPECT TO HAVE DIALOGUE ON
SPECIFICALLY- YOU'LL NOTICE THAT
IN THIS TRAILER BILL LANGUAGE
THERE IS NO. THERE ARE NO DATES
AT ALL FOR THE EFFECTIVENESS OF
THIS. THE BILL IS ENACTED OF
COURSE IT ALL BECOMES. EFFECTIVE
JULY ONE. OBVIOUSLY WE CAN'T
CHANGE THE PROCESS WITHOUT
EDUCATING PEOPLE ON WHAT THE NEW
PROCESSES DEVELOPING THE FORMS.
TRAINING THE STAFF CONDUCTING IT
WILL DOING THE ALJ TRAINING SO
SOME OF THE ROOF- PROPOSED
UPDATES TO THE PROCESS THAT
WE'RE PROPOSING. NEED TO BE
STAGGERED OVER TIME. AND SO FOR
THAT REASON AS AN EXAMPLE-
DIALOGUE REALLY NEEDS TO
CONTINUE HERE AND WE'RE OPEN TO
MAKING THIS A MUCH BETTER
PROCESS FOR THE PEOPLE WHO. NEED
AVAIL THEMSELVES OF IT. I'M
ALONG THOSE LINES AND CONTINUING
THE THEME OF EARLY. ISSUE
BROUGHT UP. THE WHAT LATER MAKE
SURE THAT PROPOSED CHANGES- THAT
WE HAVE MEASURES THAT ARE.
DETERMINING WHETHER THEY'VE BEEN
SUCCESSFUL OR NOT AND- SINCE WE
DON'T HAVE TIME. DATA INCLUDED
IN THE TRAILER BILL. WHAT IS IT
THAT WE'RE GOING TO BE FOLLOWING
TO ENSURE THAT WE'RE GETTING THE
OUTCOMES WE WANT OUT OF THIS.
WE'RE HOPING TO BE ABLE TO
PROVIDE AN UPDATE OF THE BILL
PROCESS BEFORE- TRAILER BILL
LANGUAGE SORRY BEFORE THE- THE
BUDGETS AND ACTED SO WE HOPE TO
PROVIDE SOME CERTAINTY IN THAT
REGARD- YOU YOU WILL ALSO SEE IN
OUR TRAILER BILL LANGUAGE THE
FINAL- PROBABLY SIX OR EIGHT
PAGES OF IT CONTAINED- SEVERAL.
SUCH AS WHERE TALKING IT ON
PARENTS SEE. THE INFORMATION THE
PROCESS WHO'S USING IT WHO'S NOT
USING IT WHO GOT RESOLVED AT
WHAT STEP IN THE PROCESS AND THE
TYPES OF ISSUES THAT WERE
RESOLVED SO THERE ARE. SOME
EXPAND COVERAGE OF THINGS OF
WANT TO BE TRANSPARENT ABOUT IN
THE PROCESS THAT WILL HAVE STILL
. ABOUT THE- IT DOES AS A MATTER
TATIAN. WHERE WHERE THERE ANY
LESSONS LEARNED WHEN WE S. THE
SELF DETERMINED. MMHM BUT- ARE.
THAT CAN HELP US TO INFORM THE
HEARING PRESSURING EFFORT THAT
WE'RE DOING NOW HOPING YOU CAN
COMMENT ON THAT- THE SELF
DETERMINATION PROGRAM IS A
RELATIVELY SMALL SIZE SLICE
SORRY OF THE OVERALL THING SO I
WOULD SAY NOT NECESSARILY ACCEPT
THAT I WOULD SAY WE KNOW THAT
THAT DIRECT CONNECTION TO PEOPLE
EXPERIENCING A PROCESS. REALLY
KEY TOWARD KNOWING HOW TO FIX IT
AND REFORM AT. NOT SO THAT WOULD
THAT WOULD KIND OF BE MY SHORT
ANSWER TO THAT- THE OTHER THAT I
WOULD SAY IS THAT THERE'S A LOT
OF INTEREST IN RESOLVING ISSUES
AT THE LOWEST POSSIBLE LEVEL
NOBODY WANTS TO GO TO A FORMAL
HEARING WITH A JUDGE. ONE A
SIMPLE CONVERSATION WITH THE
REGIONAL SKINNER MIGHT RESOLVE
THE ISSUE SO OUR PROPOSAL.
REALLY OUTWEIGH VERY CLEARLY-
INFORMAL MEETING PROCESS BEFORE
MEDIA. AT ANY EVENT THANK YOU.
AND THE FAMILY CAN CHOOSE ONE OF
THOSE ANY COMBINATION OF THOSE
OR ALL THREE OF THOSE. CHANGE
THEIR MIND LATER IF THEY DON'T
SEE THAT THEY'RE GETTING WHAT
THEY WANT THEY CAN ALWAYS GO
BACK AND SAY WELL WE TRIED THAT
LET'S DO THIS NEXT SO. WE TRY TO
ACCOMMODATE THAT FLEXIBILITY. IN
AND I APPRECIATE THE COMMENT YOU
HAD BECAUSE IF WE KEEP GROUNDING
OURSELVES AND THE PEOPLE WHO ARE
BENEFITING FROM THE PROGRAM
WE'RE GOING TO BE DESIGNING
BETTER PROGRAMS. ENOUGH WERE
LOOKING TOWARDS THESE FAIR
HEARINGS AND- DRAWING IN THE
PURCHASE OF SERVICES WHICH WE
KNOW. HAS BEEN HISTORICALLY A
PROBLEM WITHIN OUR THE SYSTEM. I
BELIEVE THAT BY GROUNDING
OURSELVES IN THE STORIES AND-
YEAH- EXPERIENCES. FROM OUR
COMMUNITIES WILL BETTER ALLOW US
TO HAVE PROGRAMS THAT MEET THEIR
NEEDS I BELIEVE WHAT YOU'RE
DOING HERE WITH FAIR HEARINGS
WILL ALLOW US TO. DRIVE BETTER
PROCESS SEES BUT JUST SIMPLY
WANTED TO MAKE SURE WE WERE
GROUNDING OURSELVES AND THE
PEOPLE ARE BENEFITING FROM THE
PROGRAMS AND INCLUDING THEIR
INPUT AND- MAKING CHANGES
BECAUSE OF. WITH THAT I WOULD
LIKE TO THANK VERY MUCH THIS
PANEL WE WILL HOLD THIS ITEM.WE
WILL NOW MOVE ON TO ISSUE FIVE
ON THE RESEARCH AND DATA
ENHANCEMENTS PCP WITH TRAILER
BILL LANGUAGE. WE WILL HAVE FIVE
PRESENTERS ON THIS PANEL FOR
ISSUE FIVE BEGIN WITH CARLA
CUSTOM YEAH THE- CHIEF DEPUTY
DIRECTOR OF OPERATIONS THE
DEPARTMENT OF DEVELOPMENTAL
SERVICES. FOLLOWED BY PETE
SERVING CO CHIEF DEPUTY DIRECTOR
OF DATA ANALYTICS AND STRATEGY
WITH DDS. DR VICKY LOVELL CHIEF
AUDITS AND RESEARCH WITH DDS.
FOLLOWED BY CHRISTOPHER O'NEILL
WITH DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE AND
SONYA PADDOCK WITH THE L. A. L.
LET'S BEGIN WITH CARLA
CASTANEDA. WHEN YOU'RE READY.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR IN PART
BECAUSE THE OTHER DEPARTMENT OF
DEVELOPMENTAL SERVICES ON THIS
REQUEST IS TO. DOLLARS TO BE
HIRING NINETEEN STAFF TO SUPPORT
OUR RESEARCH AND INFORMATION
TECHNOLOGY DIVISIONS. ON THIS
INCREASES TO THREE POINT THREE
MILLION ONGOING. OF THE AT THE
INTENT IS TO ENHANCE OUR
INFRASTRUCTURE CRITICAL
INFRASTRUCTURE WHICH WOULD
SUPPORT THE NEW AND CONTINUING
INITIATIVES. THIS PROPOSAL
INCLUDES THE BILL AND LANGUAGE
WOULD. PROVIDE I AM SPEND A
THIRTY FOR UNEMPLOYMENT AND
IMPLIED IN FOR. BUT IT ALSO-
HOPES TO SEE OF PROVIDE BETTER-
TRANSPARENCY FOR INFORMATION
ONLINE FOR THE TOOL IS YOUR
PARTS THANK YOU. MISTER SERVANT
CONTROL. THANK YOU I THINK YOUR
AGENDA ASK FOR SOME SPECIFIC
TANGIBLE OUTCOMES- ASK DOCTOR
LEVEL TO JUMP IN IN JUST A
MOMENT- ON THAT POINT BUT I
THINK TWO OF THE THINGS THAT
WE'VE BEEN TALKING ABOUT SYSTEM
WIDE RALLY JUMP TO MIND HERE-
THAT THE OF FIRST OF ALL- THE
QUALITY INCENTIVE INITIATIVE-
WHICH WHICH UNIVISION WHICH
WOULD BE- STANDING UP AND
REGIONAL CENTER PERFORMANCE
MEASURES IS ANOTHER ONE. THESE
EFFORTS REQUIRE AN IMMENSE
AMOUNT OF DATA STRATIFIED IN A
WAY THAT THE DEPARTMENT HERE TO
FOUR HASN'T DONE IN A FREQUENCY
THAT'S MORE THAT'S MORE REAL AND
WALL YOU DIDN'T HEAR THE WORD
CONSUMER IN EITHER OF THOSE
THINGS BETTER PERFORMANCE AND
BETTER QUALITY SERVICE IN THE
HANDS OF THE CONSUMER EXPERIENCE
SO THOSE ARE TWO EXAMPLES WHERE
DIRECTLY AS A RESULT OF THIS
INVESTMENT IN OUR CAPACITY TO
HANDLE THAT DATA. CONSUMER
OUTCOMES- AND THAT'S WHAT WILL
BE BETTER A SERVICE ACCESS AND
EQUITY IS ANOTHER EXAMPLE AND
PERHAPS I COULD TURN IT TO
DOCTOR LEVEL- TO CONTINUE TO
ANSWER TO THIS QUESTION DR LEVEL
. DR ARAMBULA THANK YOU LEVEL
CHIEF FOR THE FOR CORRECT.
RESEARCH AUDIT AND EVALUATE
BRANCH. FALLING ON ALL OF THE
DISCUSSION TODAY WHAT THE
PURPOSE F THE INITIATIVE THE
DEPARTMENT IS UNDERTAKING- AND
IN TERMS OF IMPROVING OUTCOMES
FOR CONSUMERS THAT ARE ALSO
BEING VERY CLEAR ON WHAT THOSE
OUTCOMES ARE. THIS EXPANSION
WILL PROVIDE INSIGHT INTO THE
BASELINE SITUATION AND
EXPERIENCE OF THE CONSUMER
FACING OF THE CURRENT THING
TODAY AT PARTICULARLY RELATED TO
SERVICE ACCESS AND EQUITY WE DO
HAVE A LOT. OF DATA AT A HIGH
LEVEL- REGARDING OUR COUNTRY
CONSUMERS EXPERIENCE THAT WE
OFTEN DON'T CROWD MORE DETAILED
INSIGHT BUT INDIVIDUAL CONSUMERS
THAT WE CAN AGGREGATE UP TO A
LEVEL WHERE THAT INFORMATION IS
USEFUL FOR POLICY AND PROGRAMS
ENGINE. WE REALLY WOULD BENEFIT
FROM HAPPENING ENHANCE DATA
COLLECTION AND- BUDGET RELATED
BALLOT OUTCOME IS THAT CONSUMERS
- MARKETS ARE EXPERIENCING
THEMSELVES EXPRESSED IN TERMS OF
THEIR OWN PERSONAL GOALS FOR THE
SERVICES THEY RECEIVE FROM
THEIR- REGIONAL CENTERS. I WILL
HAVE A BETTER A- AND FOLLOW
THROUGH ON CONSUMER GOAL. WHICH
WILL SUPPORT OUR HAVE TO
ANNOUNCED- PERSON SAN AND OUT
FOR. ON WITH THEM ABOUT GOALS
AND SERVICES THAT THEY WOULD
LIKE TO HAVE. BEEN ABLE TO
BETTER ADDRESS GAPS IN SERVICES
THROUGH EXPANDED DATA COLLECTION
AND BETTER DATA QUALITY MORE
TIMELY DATA UPDATES AND MORE
DETAILED UNDERSTANDING OF
BARRIERS THAT ARE FACED A WE CAN
DEVELOP APPROPRIATE SOLUTIONS.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU DEPARTMENT
OF FINANCE. CHRISTOPHER O'NEILL
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE NOTHING
FURTHER OUT ON THE SIDE OF MR
THANK YOU SUNNY PADDOCK WITH THE
L. L. FUNNY PADDOCK WITH THE L.
A. O. THERE IS ONE COMPONENT OF
THIS PROPOSAL THAT CONCERNS A
REPORT THAT WOULD BE SAID THAT
IS SUBMITTED TO THE LEGISLATURE-
THAT CONCERNS CHILDREN WHO ARE
DUALLY SUIT SERVED BY THE CHILD
WELFARE SYSTEM IN THE DEPARTMENT
OF SOCIAL SERVICES. M. BY DDS-
THE DEPARTMENT IS PROPOSING TO
INSTEAD OF SUBMITTING THIS
REPORT TO MORE REGULARLY POST
DATA ONLINE. AND- WE WOULD JUST
NOTE THAT- REPORTING ON A
PARTICULARLY VULNERABLE GROUP OF
CHILDREN IS OBVIOUSLY QUITE
IMPORTANT BUT IT ALSO NEEDS TO
BE USEFUL AND PROVIDED TO THE
RIGHT PEOPLE AT THE RIGHT TIME.
HAVING DDS AND SOCIAL SERVICES
JOINT WE POST INFORMATION ON
THEIR WEBSITES FOR PUBLIC AND
LEGISLATIVE REVIEW DOES INCREASE
TRANSPARENCY AND THAT MIGHT MAKE
SENSE. HOWEVER THE LEGISLATURE
STILL NEEDS TO UNDERSTAND WHAT'S
IMPORTANT ABOUT THIS INFORMATION
SO ONE POSSIBLE COMPROMISE OF
THE LEGISLATURE COULD CONSIDER
IT BEING THE DEPARTMENTS
PROVIDE. BILL NOTIFICATION TO
THE LEGISLATURE WHEN DATA
UPDATES ARE MADE- AND POSTED
ONLINE. AND THEN- ACTUALLY THE
LEGISLATURE COULD CONSIDER
HAVING THE DEPARTMENTS IN THE
SPESSART OF DISTILL IMPORTANT
FINDINGS FOR THE LEGISLATURE SO
PERHAPS THAT COULD BE THROUGH
THE OFFICIAL NOTIFICATION OR
PERHAPS THEY COULD OFFER.
BRIEFINGS TO LEGISLATIVE STAFF
WERE PERHAPS THERE'S ANOTHER
MEANS- THAT COULD BE
BRAINSTORMED- IN ADDITION- WE'D
IN CLOSING NOTE THAT GIVEN THE
AMOUNT OF TIME THAT HAS PASSED
SINCE THE REPORTING REQUIREMENT
WAS FIRST CODIFIED. THE
LEGISLATURE MIGHT WISH TO
CONSIDER WHETHER OR BENEFIT FROM
ANY CHANGES TO THE REQUIREMENTS
SO FOR EXAMPLE PERHAPS IT WOULD
BENEFIT FROM GETTING MORE
INFORMATION FROM THE TWO
DEPARTMENTS ABOUT OUTCOMES FOR
THE CHILDREN WHO ARE DULY SERVED
BY THE TWO DEPARTMENTS- IN
ADDITION TO SOME OF THE
INFORMATION THAT'S ALREADY
REPORTED ON. LIKE BASIC NUMBERS
OF KIDS AND- SORT OF PROCESS
ORIENTED TYPE MEASURES. THANK
YOU I WILL BRING IT UP TO THE
DÍAS TO SEE IF ANY MEMBERS HAVE
QUESTIONS- FIRST OLD ALL STAR
JUST BY SAYING HOW INTERESTED MY
OFFICE IS IN. BOTH COLLECTION OF
DATA AND THEN THE ANALYSIS THAT
COMES WITH IT AS- THAT WHICH IS
NOT MEASURED CANNOT BE IMPROVED.
AND SOME VERY GRATEFUL THAT THE
DEPARTMENT IS WILLING TO. TACKLE
THIS AND TO START ASKING AND
ANSWERING SOME OF THE DIFFICULT
QUESTIONS. BUT WOULD LIKE TO GET
TO THE REPORTING IF I CAN AS I
THINK IT'S IMPORTANT TO. MAKE
SURE THAT IT'S REPORTED BUT THAT
IT'S MEANINGFUL- IS IT POSSIBLE
FOR US TO BOTH BE NOTIFIED AND
OR GET A SUMMARY OF- WHAT THE
DATA IS SHOWING HOW CAN WE MAKE
SURE THAT WERE INCLUDED AS
YOU'RE SUBMITTING THAT
INFORMATION. ABSOLUTELY I THINK
THE WHOLE POINT OF THE DATA
COLLECTION AND ANALYSIS AND
INTERPRETATION IS TO INFORM
PUBLIC POLICY AND THAT IS NOT
JUST THE ADMINISTRATION BUT THE
LEGISLATURE AS WELL. WE DON'T
ENVISION POSTING STATIC DATA
TABLES- THERE WITH NO
EXPLANATION OF WHAT IT MEANS AND
WHAT WE MIGHT CONSIDER AS A
RESULT. UP BITS OF THAT ARE IN
THE CURRENT FORMAL REPORT THAT'S
THAT'S PRODUCED- BUT I WOULD SAY
THAT WITH THEIR OPPORTUNITIES
THERE TO MAKE THAT BOTH MORE
USEFUL AS THE L. A. O.
SUGGESTED. AND MORE ACCESSIBLE
TO THE PUBLIC THAN THAN IT'S
CURRENTLY DONE AND SO THAT'S A
VERY CONSISTENT WITH OUR INTENT.
LEGISLATIVE NOTIFICATION COULD
CAN HAPPEN WE MEET WITH YOUR
TEAM DOES STAFF QUARTERLY WE CAN
TELL THEM WHEN THE WEBSITES
UPDATED THIS. HAVING TO PHD IS A
MY OFF SAID- AND HAVE. RESEARCH
BACKGROUNDS ALSO A THIS TO BE ON
ALLOWS OUR UNIVERSITIES AND
RESEARCHERS TO BE FOLLOWING AND
GATHERING THIS INFORMATION WHICH
IS NECESSARY SO ONCE TO THANK
VERY MUCH THIS PANEL WILL HOLD
THIS ITEM OPEN WE WILL NOW MOVE
ON TO THE DEPARTMENT OF
REHABILITATION PROPOSALS. WE
WILL START ON ISSUE SIX ON THE
DISABILITY INNOVATION FUND BCP
WE WILL HAVE FOUR PRESENTERS ON
THIS PANEL FOR ISSUE SIX
BEGINNING WITH JOSIE BEER
DIRECTOR FOR THE DEPARTMENT OF
REHABILITATION TRONG LEAD
ASSISTANT DEPUTY DIRECTOR FOR
VOCATIONAL REHABILITATION
EMPLOYMENT DIVISION WITH THE
DEPARTMENT OF REHABILITATION.
JALIL BAKER FINANCE BUDGET
ANALYST WITH DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE SONYA PADDOCK WITH THE
L. L. LET'S BEGIN WITH DIRECTORS
EASIER PLEASE BEGIN WHEN YOU ARE
READY. XAVER DIRECT FOR THE
PARTNERING BOTH PATIENT MISTER
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS OF THANK YOU
FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO BE HERE
AND TO SHARE OUR PROPOSALS
WITHIN TODAY. I WANTED TO JUST
TAKE A FEW MINUTES AND SET SOME
FOUNDATIONAL- BLOCKS FOR THE TWO
PROPOSALS THAT JUGGLING- TO HEAR
TODAY. FIRST OF ALL- CHIEF TO
BOTH OF THESE PROPOSALS IS THE
BELIEF THAT INDIVIDUALS WITH
MOST SIGNIFICANT DISABILITIES
HAVE THE TALENT AND HAVE THE
POTENTIAL TO BECOME GAINFULLY
EMPLOYED. AS WELL AS THAT WE
KNOW HOW OLD THAT EMPLOYMENT IS
A PILLAR OF HEALTH. AND THAT
WERE INDIVIDUALS HAVE THE
OPPORTUNITY TO BE GAINFULLY
EMPLOYED THEY HAVE THE
OPPORTUNITY NOT ONLY TO HAVE-
ACCESS TO BETTER HEALTH. BUT TO
THEMSELVES BENEFITING FROM THAT
. THE OTHER I ELEMENT THAT IS
IMPORTANT IN IN BOTH OF THESE
PROPOSALS IS REALLY THE- WHOLE
PERSON APPROACH WHICH MEANS
WE'RE LOOKING AT THE PERSON ON A
MORE HOLISTIC WAY FOR PROVIDING
MORE OF A OF A SHE WENT SERVICE
APPROACH. TO MEETING THAT
INDIVIDUALS MATES AND THEN GOING
UPSTREAM OF THE INDIVIDUAL
EXPERIENCE AND BEGINNING TO
ENGAGE WITH THE INDIVIDUAL.%
ORDER YOUR AND THERE WERE SOME
TIME FRAMES ARE AND THEIR
EXPERIENCE JUST MEANS THAT
THEY'REBETTER PREPARED. FOR
EVENTUAL EMPLOYMENT OUTCOMES.
AND THE OTHER THING THAT IS
IMPORTANT AND THESE PROPOSALS IS
OUR CONTINUED- BELIEVES IN
ENSURING THAT- THE INDIVIDUALS
THAT ARE BEING SERVED ARE ALL
REPRESENTED. IN THE SERVICE
DELIVERY ITSELF YOU'LL HEAR THAT
ESPECIALLY IN OUR OPIOID
PROPOSAL NUMBER YOU'LL SEE THAT
COME THROUGH. AND THEN OF
COURSE- ONE OF THESE THAT THEY
FEDERAL GRANT AND SO WE CONTINUE
TO BE VERY. I'M RESPONSIBLE AS
WE CAN BE HERE TO CONTINUE TO
BRING ADDITIONAL DOLLARS INTO
CALIFORNIA CHAIR SERVE
INDIVIDUALS WITH DISABILITIES
AND PARTICULARLY WHEN- THEY COME
IN THE FORM OF A 100% I'M
FEDERAL DOLLARS. AND THEN JUST
FINALLY BEFORE I KICK IT OVER
CHIP MY CALLING MR ABOUT TRUMP
LEADERSHIP TO CHECK THIS OUT- ON
THE GRANTS- SHOWING ALWAYS
APPRECIATE OUR PARTNERSHIP- WITH
THE LEGISLATURE IN ADVANCE OF
THE WORK THAT WE'RE DOING HERE
SO. I'LL STOP YOUR COMMENTS
THURMOND AND WITH THE CHURCH
FROM KICKED OVER TO MY THE TO
SPEAK TO THE- SECTORS. FOR THANK
YOU. AND AFTER CHAIR OF. THE
COMMITTEE- MY NAME'S CHARLIE OUT
OF THIS DEPUTY- OF THEM SO GIVE
. BUT THE DEPARTMENT
REPUBLICATION- IT'S AN HONOR FOR
ME BE HERE TODAY AND THANK FOR
THE OFFER. TO PROVIDE THIS OF
THE PATH TO SUCCESS- LAST
SPRING- THE FEDERAL DEPARTMENT
OF EDUCATION POSTED A
SOLICITATION PROPOSAL FOR A
DISABILITY INNOVATION FUND
GRANTS- STABLE CATION-
REHABILITATION AGENCIES ONE
COURTS TO APPLY. FOR THIS FIVE
YEAR GRANT FOR UP TO A TOTAL OF
EIGHTEEN POINT THREE MILLION
DOLLARS. I WILL APPLY FOR THIS
COMPETITIVE GRANT. AND THIS
ABSOLUTELY- THIS PAST SEPTEMBER.
AND THE ALARM WAS A WATER THE
FULL GRANT AMOUNT OF EIGHTEEN
POINT THREE MILLION. TO
IMPLEMENT THE PATHWAY TO SUCCESS
OUR SUCCESS PROGRAM- THIS
PROGRAM IS INTENDED TO INCREASE
THE PARTICIPATION RATE FOR
INDIVIDUALS WITH DISABILITIES.
IN HIGHWAY H. HI SKILL IN HIGH
DEMAND CAREERS. INCLUDING THOSE
IN SCIENCE TECHNOLOGY
ENGINEERING AND MATHEMATICS-
THROUGH THE IMPLEMENTATION OF
SECTOR SPECIALIST TEAMS. THAT
HAVE THE TRAINING TOOLS-
KNOWLEDGE. AND RESOURCES TO
SUPPORT- INDIVIDUAL DISABILITY
SEEKING EMPLOYMENT. IN SELECTED
SECTORS REGARDLESS OF WHERE IN
CALIFORNIA THEY MIGHT LEFT- IN
PARTICULAR. THIS PROGRAM IS TO-
TARGET AT UNDER WRAPS
INDIVIDUALS UP THE- COULDN'T
PEOPLE COLOR- WATERMEN'S. AND IN
THE WERE INTO. OR DEVELOPMENT
TO. I DON'T. THE FEDERAL AWARD
DOES NOT REQUIRE STATE. I'M THE
PROGRAM THESE- PROJECT AND EVENT
AND THE VALUE PLAN ALREADY IN
DETAIL IN OUR APPROVAL- APPROVED
GRAND PROPOSAL AND DETERMINE THE
WORK THAT WE ARE PERFORMING HOW
TO IMPLEMENT THIS PROJECT. OUR
OVERARCHING GOAL OF THIS
INNOVATIVE INNOVATIVE PRODUCTS
IS TO TEST A NEW SERVICE
DELIVERY MODEL. COLLAPSED IT
EVALUATE PERFORMANCE- AND
OUTCOME DATA TO SEE HOW THIS
MODEL IMPACT. VOCATIONAL
REHABILITATION CONSUMERS
OUTCOMES- THE- I WILL COLLECT
DEMOGRAPHIC BACKGROUND IN CASE
INFORMATION ARE APPROXIMATELY
FOURTEEN HUNDRED PARTICIPATING
IN AN INDIVIDUAL WITH
DISABILITIES OFFICE CHAIR WITH A
HIGH VALUATION PARTNERS TO
FULFILL THE WORKSPACE OF
REPORTING REQUIREMENTS- THIS
WILL INCLUDE TRACKING SERVICE
DELIVERY PARTICIPANTS. PARK LAST
MARCH IN PROGRESS- INCLUDING
MOST IMPORTANTLY EMPLOYMENT
OUTCOME DATA FOR PARTICIPANTS-
I'D LIKE ALSO TO NOTE THAT WE
ARE JUST OVER HALFWAY THROUGH
THE FIRST YEAR THIS FIVE D. IS
GRANT FUNDED PROJECT. WHICH
BEGAN ON OCTOBER FIRST TWENTY
TWENTY ONE- THEREFORE THE
PROGRAM ACTIVITIES BEEN CENTER
OF ALL THE IMPLEMENTATION OF THE
PROGRAM DESIGN AND SETTING UP-
THE VALUATION COMPONENTS. AND SO
FAR- WE HAVE COMPLETED THE
FOLLOWING ACTIVITIES- NEGOTIATED
AND IN IMPLEMENTED A MULTI YEAR
CONTRACT A PROBLEM WITH OUR
PROJECT EVALUATOR AND TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE PARTNER STUDY GOES
STATE UNIVERSITY- OPTING
INSTITUTIONAL REVIEW BOARD-
APPROVAL FOR THE PROJECT
EVALUATION. OFF ON THE COMMITTEE
FOR THE PROTECTION OF HUMAN
SUBJECTS- WE COMPLETED THE
RECRUITMENT OF SELECTED- SECTOR
SPECIALIZATION TEAMS THAT. ARE
OUT WILL HAPPEN AGAIN- WE GOT AT
THE END OF FINING AND ROLLING
PARTICIPANT AND CONTACTING-
SECTOR EMPLOYERS. ONLY WOULD
HAVE ABOUT NINETY NINE OKAY BUT
THE SPENT IN THIS. THE TIME-
DEVELOPED AND IMPLEMENTED
TRACKING TO ATTEND WHO
PARTICIPANTS. OKAY UP AND IT'S
BEEN. ARE REGULATED. TO OUR
SCOPE OF. WHAT CONTRA WORK OUR
TO AND TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE
PROVIDERS- STANDER- STANFORD
YOU'LL OR WHATEVER CITY AND
UCLA'S TARJAN CENTER- WHAT
ANTICIPATED CONTRACT START DATE
OF JULY FIRST TWENTY TWENTY TWO-
COMPLETE TRAPS OF MARKETING
MATERIALS- FOR DISTRIBUTION TO
STAKEHOLDERS. AND BUSINESS
PARTNERS AND ALSO- JUSTICE ARE-
ADDITIONAL NOTE- EVEN THOUGH WE
JUST STARTED I'M VERY PROUD TO
SAY THAT WE HAVE ALREADY
RECEIVED A VERY MOVING- THANK
YOU CAR FROM ONE OF OUR
PARTICIPANTS WORKING WITH A
WONDERFUL COUNSELOR. I
SUPPORTING THE HEALTHCARE SECTOR
THIRTEEN. ARM SO YEAH WELL WE'RE
VERY EXCITED ABOUT THIS PROJECT
IN THE POSSIBILITIES IT PRESENTS
OUT TO IMPROVE SERVICE DELIVERY
TO MEET THE NEEDS OF OUR
CONSUMERS I WOULD DISABILITIES
AND IS LOOKING FOR OUR FOR
PROFIT TALENTS. AGAIN THANK YOU
SO MUCH FOR THE UP TO PURSUE
THIS PRICE. AND- FOR INTO AND
THAT- I'LL BE MORE TO. ANSWER
ANY ADDITIONAL QUESTIONS YOU MAY
. THANK YOU. THANK YOU NEXT
WE'LL HEAR FROM ILLEGAL BAKER
WITH THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE.
YES GOOD AFTERNOON HERE MEMBERS
TO THE BAKER WITH THE DEPARTMENT
OF FINANCE WE JUST LIKE TO PUT
SOME CONTEXT AROUND THIS ISSUE.
THE NOTIFICATION TO THE
LEGISLATURE AND THIS B. C. P.
ACTUALLY SERVES THE FIRST
NOTIFICATION TO THE LEGISLATURE
OF THIS GRANT AND NORMALLY WHEN
IT DEPARTMENT RECEIVES.
ADDITIONAL FEDERAL FUNDS FINANCE
WOULD NOTIFY THE LEGISLATURE
THROUGH WHAT IS CALLED A SECTION
TWENTY EIGHT LETTER- TO REQUEST
ADDITIONAL FEDERAL FUNDED
THROUGH ALREADY IN THE CURRENT
YEAR HOWEVER IN THIS INSTANCE AT
D. O. R. HAD SUFFICIENT FEDERAL
FUNDS A THIRTY IN THE CURRENT
YEAR. AND DID NOT NEED
ADDITIONAL EXPENDITURE AUTHORITY
AND THEREFORE A SECTION TWENTY
EIGHT LETTER WAS NOT EXPLICITLY
NECESSARY BUT WE STILL WANT TO
MAKE SURE WE HAD THE PROPER
NOTIFICATION- BUT WITH
UNFORTUNATELY BEGAN. REVIEWING
THIS REQUEST AT CLOSE TO THE
TIMELINE FOR APRIL BCPS AND MADE
THE DECISION TO- NOTIFY THE
LEGISLATIVE LEGISLATURE OF THIS
ADDITIONAL FUNDING. IN THE
BUDGET YEAR- IN THAT THIS GRANT
PROVIDES- THROUGH THIS B. C.
PIECE OF THIS IS THE FIRST TIME
THAT WE'RE HEARING ABOUT IT.
FIND ABOUT THIS BUT JUST WANTED
TO PER SOME ADDITIONAL
INFORMATION ON THAT. THANK Q.
SENATE PADDOCK WITH THE L. L. I
THANK YOU WE'VE RIVER THE
PROPOSAL AND DO NOT HAVE MAJOR
CONCERNS AND MISTER BAKER
ADDRESSED- ONE OF OUR SORT OF
PRACTICAL. CONCERNS THANK YOU
GREAT I WILL BRING IT UP TO THE
DÍAS FOR ANY MEMBERS QUESTIONS
AND KEEP IT HERE AT THE CHAIR
I'M WOULD LIKE TO GET AN
UNDERSTANDING OF SCOPE HOW MANY
INDIVIDUALS ARE GOING ARE ARE
EXPECTED TO BE SERVED BY THIS
PROJECT AND- OVER WHAT TIME
FRAME AND AGAIN. HOW WILL WE BE
MEASURING RESULTS- WILL THERE BE
METRICS AND OUTCOMES THAT WE'RE
FOLLOWING AND OW WILL THESE BE
COMMUNICATED WITH THE
LEGISLATURE ON A REGULAR BASIS.
THANK YOU FOR THE QUESTION UP
ALL START THIS OFFER THEN KICK
IT OVER TO MISTER LEE. SO LET
LET ME START WITH THE EVALUATION
PART- FIRST SO THIS IS OF COURSE
I'M A FIVE YEAR GRANTS A FEDERAL
GRANT AND THERE'S AN ELEMENT OF
THAT GRANT A FORMAL EVALUATION.
FROM IS- REQUIRED. AND SO WE
WILL BE PREPARING THAT WE'VE
ACTUALLY CONTRACTED WITH- ONE OF
THE UNIVERSITIES TO CONDUCT THAT
EVALUATION. CERTAINLY MAKING
THAT AVAILABLE. TO THE
LEGISLATURE IS WHAT NOT AN ISSUE
AT ALL- BUT KNOWING THAT THAT
REALLY IS LIKELY TO TAKE PLACE
IN YOUR FIVE OR SIX- WE DO HAVE-
ANNUAL PROGRESS REPORTS AND I'M
NOT QUITE SURE HOW FORMATIVE
THOSE WOULD BE BUT CERTAINLY
GLAD TO. COME BACK IN AND SHARE-
ANY UPDATES OR ANYTHING IS THAT
WE HAVE LEARNED IN THE
INTERVENING YEARS WORTH OF THE
LEGISLATURE- SO. OPEN TO THAT- I
THINK IN TERMS OF. THE ACTUAL
VOLUME PARTICIPANTS REPORT
TALKING SOMEWHERE AROUND
FOURTEEN FIFTEEN HUNDRED THIS IS
STATEWIDE- AND IS TRONG
MENTIONED EARLIER IN. THE
APPLICATION ITSELF IN THE IN THE
GRANT ITSELF THERE ARE A NUMBER
OF DATA ELEMENTS THAT ARE
REQUIRED TO BE COLLECTED. AND
REPORTED ANNUALLY SO- STRUGGLE
TO GET TO YOU IF YOU CAN
HIGHLIGHT JUST WHAT A COUPLE OF
THOSE MONEY THE- TICKET. AND-
CHERUB WE S. TO- TO BE SERVING-
APPROXIMATELY FOURTEEN HUNDRED-
BUT JUST A BIT AND- GOING TO
CREATE A FIVE YEARS. AND WILL BE
MATCHING SOME OF SOME OF THE
MEASURE AND- GOALS THAT WE HAVE
THIS SYSTEM YOU KNOW MEASURABLE
SKILL GAINS- WHETHER OR NOT. YOU
SHOULD THE TRAINING- THEIR
ABILITY TO ENTER INTO
COMPETITIVE INTEGRATED
EMPLOYMENT- INCREASED OUR
EARNINGS- AND WITH OPTIONAL
RELIANCE ON ON PUBLIC SERVICE-
SO THOSE ARE WILL BE SOME OF THE
MEASURE- MEASUREMENTS THAT WILL
BE LOOKING AT- STYLE I'M NOT
SURE IF YOU HAVE ANY- FOLLOW UP
QUESTIONS. NO I'M I'M IN
CREDIBLY ENCOURAGED. BY THE-
RECEIPT OF THESE FUNDS THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT I THINK THE
REASON WHY I'M ASKING FOR THE
FOLLOW UP ON METRICS IS. THAT
I'M ANTICIPATING US TO HAVE GOOD
RESULTS FROM THIS INNOVATION
FUND AND IF WERE HAVING THOSE
RESULTS PRIOR TO THE- COMPLETION
OF THE GRANT FUNDING AND THE
EVALUATION IT WOULD BE NICE TO
HAVE THAT INFORMATION AS A
LEGISLATURE SO WE CAN DETERMINE
WHETHER WE- NEEDED TO INCREASE.
THE FUNDS AMOUNT AND THUS I
THINK WHAT WE'RE LOOKING FOR IS.
A MORE INTUITIVE. OF
RELATIONSHIP WITH THE
INFORMATION AS WE'RE GOING
THROUGH THIS GRANT CYCLE AND-
JUST HOPING TO HAVE THAT LEVEL
OF COMMUNICATION WITH THE- THANK
YOU I'M TERRIBLE AND WHEN WE
WILL. BE- YOU KNOW GATHERING
REPORTS AS WE PROGRESS- AND WILL
BE MAKING THOSE REPORTS
AVAILABLE FOR THE MUCH TO ENSURE
. I THANK YOU FOR THAT I LOOK
FORWARD TO IT I THINK IT'S
INCREDIBLY IMPORTANT FOR US TO
WORK ON COMPETITIVE INTEGRATED
EMPLOYMENT AND I LOOK FORWARD TO
THIS INNOVATION FUND AND THE
SUCCESS THAT YOU HAVE WITH. WITH
THAT I WILL THANK VERY MUCH THIS
PANELWE WILL HOLD THIS ITEM
OPEN AND WE WILL NOW MOVE ON TO
ISSUE SEVEN. WHICH IS ON THE
OPIOID SETTLEMENT FUND
INTEGRATING EMPLOYMENT AND
RECOVERY PROGRAM PCP. WE WILL
HAVE FOUR PRESENTERS ON THIS
PANEL FOR ISSUE SEVEN BEGINNING
WITH DIRECTOR JOE XAVIER
DEPARTMENT OF REAL DILATATION.
MARC PERLICH MEN DEPUTY DIRECTOR
OF VOCATIONAL REHABILITATION
EMPLOYMENT DIVISION DO ARE.
CHILLY OLD BAKER WITH DO F. AND
SONYA PADDOCK WITH THE L. A. M.
LET'S BEGIN WITH DIRECTORS A
PEER PLEASE BEGIN WHEN YOU ARE
READY. OVER ARCHING COMMENTS
EARLIER SO ARE I WILL NOT REPEAT
THOUSAND I'LL JUST TURN IT OVER
TO. MR ALTMAN CHAIR WILL PROVIDE
THE DETAILS OF THE PROPOSAL. AT
THANK YOU FOR YOUR TAKE HERE- AT
AND THANK YOU CHAIR FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO SHARE INFORMATION
ON OUR PROPOSED INTEGRATED
EMPLOYMENT AND RECOVERY PROGRAM-
THE PARTITION IS REQUESTING FOUR
MILLION DOLLARS FROM THE OPIOID
SETTLEMENT FUNDS TO ESTABLISH
THE PILOT INTEGRATED EMPLOYMENT
IN RECOVERY R. I. E. R. PROGRAM
. THROUGH THIS PILOT YOU ARE
WILL FORM A TEAM THAT WILL
PROVIDE TRAINING TO THE PROVIDER
WORKFORCE ON EVIDENCE BASED
PRACTICES TO SERVE PEOPLE WITH
SUBSTANCE USE DISORDER.
SPECIFICALLY RELATED TO OPIOID
USE- WE PLANNED IT OUT THIS
TRAINING COMPANY HOPE CAN BE
CORPORATE AS PART OF A HOLISTIC
RECOVERY APPROACH. THE TRAINING
WILL FOCUS ON INCORPORATING THE
FULL RANGE OF VOCATIONAL
RELOCATION SERVICES INTO A
PARTICIPANT'S TREATMENT IT'S
PART OF A WHOLE PERSON APPROACH
TO RECOVERY. TO DEVELOP AND
PROVIDE SUPPORTS FOR INDIVIDUALS
RETURNING TO OUR TRANSITION INTO
WORK DURING AND FOLLOWING
TREATMENT. STILL VERY MUCH IN
CONCERT WITH THE BELIEF THAT
EMPLOYMENT CAN AND SHOULD E AN
INTEGRAL PART OF AND CAN ENHANCE
THE RECOVERY PROCESS AND NOT BE
SOMETHING THAT IS POSTPONED
UNTIL THE COMPLETION OF
TREATMENT. YOUR PROPOSES TO
PROVIDE EMPLOYMENT SERVICES AND
A MINIMUM OF FOUR TREATMENT
CENTERS BY COMPLICATING STAFF IN
THE SELECTED CENTERS. THAT ARE
TREATING DIVERSE UNDERSERVED
COMMUNITIES. PARTICULARLY IN
THOSE COMMUNITIES THAT HAVE
SUFFERED SEVERE AND DISPARATE
IMPACT FROM THE OPIOID EPIDEMIC
. SERVICES WOULD INCLUDE
EMPLOYMENT SKILLS DEVELOPMENT
COUNSELING GUIDANCE ON
EMPLOYMENT OPTIONS JOB PLACEMENT
IN ADVOCACY FOR. AN
IDENTIFICATION OF LONG TERM
EMPLOYMENT SUPPORTS THE PEOPLE
WITH SUBSTANCE USE DISORDER
RELATED TO OPIATE USE MAY
REQUIRE TO BE SUCCESSFUL THE
WORKPLACE. WE'RE PROPOSING TO
BREAK DOWN THE SPENDING AS
FOLLOWS- FOR THE PROVIDER
WORKFORCE TRAINING PROGRAM WE
PROPOSED ONE POINT TWO MILLION
TO BE SPENT OVER THREE YEARS TO
SUPPORT A TRAINING TEAM
CONSISTING OF ABOUT FOUR POINT
FOUR FULL TIME EQUIVALENT STAFF.
AND OPERATING EXPENSES THAT WILL
PROVIDE TRAINING ON EVIDENCE
BASED PRACTICES TO PROVIDERS OF
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH SERVICES TO
PEOPLE WITH DISABILITIES AND
SUBSTANCE USE DISORDERS RELATED
TO OPIOID USE. ONE POINT
SERVICES TO BE PROVIDED
TREATMENT CENTER PORTION WE'RE
PROPOSING TO SPEND TWO POINT
EIGHT MILLION DOLLARS AGAIN OVER
THREE YEARS TO SUPPORT LOCATION
RELOCATION PLANNING SERVICES
TEAM. OF APPROXIMATELY THREE AND
A HALF FULL TIME EQUIVALENT
STAFF. TO BE COLOCATED IN
TREATMENT CENTERS IN TARGETED
REGIONS THROUGHOUT THE STATE THE
SURVIVORS COMMUNITIES AS AN
INTEGRAL PART. OF BEHAVIORAL
HEALTH AND SUBSTANCE USE
TREATMENT. IN ADDITION TO THE
STAFF THESE FUNDS WOULD SUPPORT
OPERATING EXPENSES AND
PARTICIPANT COSTS FOR EXAMPLE.
THE GOODS OR SERVICES NECESSARY
FOR THE PARTICIPANTS TO
PARTICIPATE IN JOB TRAINING WORK
BASED LEARNING OPPORTUNITIES
TRANSPORTATION WORK TOOLS
UNIFORMS. AND SO FORTH. I'M WE
ARE HAPPY TO- TWO OF THEM. AND
PREPARE TO RESPOND ANY
ADDITIONAL QUESTIONS- THE CHAIR
OF THE COMMITTEE MAY HAVE. THANK
YOU ILLEGAL BAKER WITH
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE. IT WILL
BAKER WITH THE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE NOTHING FURTHER. INTO
QUESTIONS SENATE PADDOCK WITH
THE L. L. SUNNY PETTICOAT THE L.
A- OUR MAIN COMMENT- SORT OF
REPEATS A THEME THAT'S BEEN
COMMON THROUGHOUT THIS- HEARING
TODAY AND THAT IS THAT- THE
DEPARTMENT AS HAS NOT WORKED OUT
YET HOW WOULD YOU EVALUATE THIS
NOVEL PILOT PROGRAM TO DETERMINE
WHETHER IT'S SUCCESSFUL AND
SHOULD BE REPLICATED IN OTHER
AREAS OF THE STATE. I'M IN
CONVERSATIONS WITH THE
DEPARTMENT- THEY INDICATED THEY
ARE THINKING ABOUT HOW TO DO
THIS BUT WE JUST NOTE THAT AS
WRITTEN THE PROPOSAL DOES
INCLUDE ANY EVALUATIONS THAT
GUARANTEE FOR THE LEGISLATURE
THAT IT WOULD ACTUALLY HAPPEN-
WE THINK THIS WOULD BE A MISSED
OPPORTUNITY AND SUGGEST THE
LEGISLATURE- CONSIDER ADDING
SUCH REQUIREMENTS. WE'LL BRING
IT NOW UP TO THE DIGESTIVE IF
ANY MEMBERS HAVE QUESTIONS AND
KEEP IT HERE AT THE CHAIR WOULD
LOVE TO FOLLOW UP WITH THE
DEPARTMENT IF I CAN IN RESPONSE
TO. THE L. A- HOPING YOU CAN
COMMENT ON HOW WE WILL BE
EVALUATING THIS PROGRAM AS WELL
AS THE TIMELINE THAT WE HAVE FOR
PROGRAM DEVELOPMENT. AND WHEN WE
CAN EXPECT THIS PROGRAM TO BEGIN
OPERATING. SO ALL START THAT NON
GERMAN SO WITH THE WITH THE
EVALUATION WILL CLEARLY WILL BE
DOING AN EVALUATION HERE IS MUCH
BETTER BECAUSE AS NOTED- EARNING
HER. ONE OF THE THINGS THAT WERE
WANTING TO ENSURE IS WHAT NOT
JUST MEASURING TO TASK AND
ACTIVITY HOW MANY PEOPLE THAT WE
SERVE OUR HOW MANY SERVICES THAT
WE PROVIDE. BUT REALLY MEASURING
WHAT IS THE IMPACT OF THE
SERVICES ON OF THE INDIVIDUAL.
CHAU AS AN EXAMPLE INDIVIDUALS
WHO MAKE A WIN FOR SUBSTANCE USE
DISORDER TREATMENT- MATE. WAIT
AND COME BACK AT A LATER POINT
IN SO THAT PATH THAT THEY'RE
GOING TO TRAVEL IS NOT GOING TO
BE A LANDING GEAR AND SO WE- NOT
ONLY DO WE WANT TO BE THOUGHTFUL
ABOUT WHAT THOSE. MEASURES ARE
GOING TO BE OF THAT IMPACT BUT
BUT AS WE'RE WORKING WITH- THE
TREATMENT PARTNERS WE ALSO WANT
TO MAKE SURE THAT WE'RE
INCLUDING THEM IN THAT
CONVERSATION. SO WE WILL.
DEFINITELY BE EVALUATING THIS
AND CERTAINLY. SHARING THAT-
BACK WITH THE LEGISLATURE GLAD
TO DO SO AND MCCARTY YOUR
TRADITIONAL DETAILS THE- RIGHT.
THANK YOU DIRECTORS EVER AS AS
DIRECTORS EVER NOTED- WE ARE
PROPOSING TO COLLECT IN AND OUT
AND ANALYZE DATA THE TRAINING
AND EMPLOYMENT SERVICES EFFORTS
TO SUPPORTS TRAINING PROGRAM
IMPROVEMENTS. THIS WILL INCLUDE
PROVIDER WORKFORCE PARTICIPATION
AND TRAINING SATISFACTION AND
PARTICIPATION IN PROTESTS IN
SATISFACTION AND OUTCOMES WE
PLAN TO TRACK A VARIETY DATA
INCLUDING THE NUMBER OF
INDIVIDUALS WHO RECEIVE
EMPLOYMENT. TRAINING THROUGH THE
HEALTHCARE SYSTEM PROVIDER
WORKFORCE TRAINING PROGRAM THE
NUMBER OF INDIVIDUALS RECEIVED
EMPLOYMENT SERVICES TO THE PILOT
PROGRAM TO INCLUDE TYPE AND
LENGTH OF SERVICE. THE NUMBER OF
INDIVIDUALS WHO EMPLOYER THE
RESOLUTION OF TREATMENT SERVICES
AND THE NUMBER OF INDIVIDUALS
WHO DROP OUT OR DISCONTINUE
PLUMBING SERVICES WHILE IN
TREATMENT AND AFTER TREATMENT-
WE'RE ALSO GOING TO BE- TRACKING
THE RECIPIENT OR GRAPHIC DATA.
WHEN. IT'S PROVIDED BY THE
TREATMENT PARTNER. DESTRUCTOR
EXAM NO NO YOU KNOW OF INCOME
NATURE OF SUBSTANCE USE
TREATMENT PARTICULARLY THOSE
FIRST ENTERING INTO WERE SEEKING
TREATMENT. AND MULTIPLE CO
OCCURRING DISABILITIES AND
INDIVIDUALS WITH SUBSTANCE USE
DISORDERS RELATED TO OPIOID USE.
WE WANT TO BE CAUTIOUS ABOUT
SETTING PROJECTED
QUALIFICATIONS. THERE MENTION WE
DON'T WANT TO MEASURE TASK AN
ACTIVITY WE WANT TO MEASURE
OUTCOMES. INSTANCE THIS IS NEW
WE WANT TO ENSURE THAT THE GOALS
ARE REALISTIC AND REFLECT THE
ACTUAL IMPACT OF THE SERVICES.
THEREFORE WE WILL NEED TO WORK
WITH THE TREATMENT CENTERS AND
THEIR STAFF TO JOIN ESTABLISH
EFFECTIVE MEANS AND TARGETS TO
MEASURE THE IMPACT OF SERVICES
ON OUTCOMES. WE'RE EXTREMELY
INTERESTED IN AND OUT AND-
EAGER. TO DETERMINE THE EFFICACY
OF THESE SERVICES AND- EXPAND.
THEM WHEN- POSSIBLE. IN REGARDS
TO THE CHAIRS- RELAY TIMELINE-
GONNA BE ONE OF BE ONE MAKE SURE
THAT TRAINING IS DEVELOP
CONTRACTS WITH THE CHEN TRAINING
THAT WILL BE OFFERED TO THE
PROVIDER. SO WE PROPOSED BELIEVE
IT STARTING IN JULY THROUGH THE
END OF AUGUST THE TWENTY TWENTY
TWO WE PLAN TO CONDUCT THE
RECRUITMENT FOR THE MANAGER AND
THE TRAINING STAFF THEY'LL
DELIVERING THE TRAINING. AND
CONCURRENTLY WITH THAT
ECRUITING WE PLAN TO MEET WITH
THE HEALTH CARE SYSTEM LEADERS
TO UNDERSTAND CURRENT TRAINING
FRAMEWORKS AND HOW THESE BR
SERVICES TRAININGS MAYBE
CORPORATE INTO THEIR NEW OR
EXISTING TRAININGS. NOT
BEGINNING SEPTEMBER OF THIS YEAR
TWENTY TWENTY TO THE TRAINING
TEAM WOULD BEGIN WORKING ON
SPECIFIC SUBSTANCE USE. RECOVERY
FOCUSED APPOINTMENTS SERVICES
TRAINING CONTENT. BEGINNING IN
LATE NOVEMBER TWENTY TWENTY TWO-
JUNE TWENTY TWENTY FIVE WITH
PLANET DELIVERING THIS TRAINING
TO POP YOUR PROVIDER WORKFORCE
IN CONJUNCTION WITH THEIR
EXISTING A TRAINING- FOR THE
PILOT EMPLOYMENT SERVICES IN THE
TREATMENT CENTERS- RECOGNIZING
THAT THERE WILL BE MULTIPLE
POSSIBLE LOCATIONS WE WANT TO BE
PARTICULARLY JUDICIOUS AND
SELECTING FOR PILOT EMPLOYMENT
SERVICES LOCATIONS. I AM
ENGAGING TREATMENT CENTER
STARTING THIS JULY TWENTY TWENTY
TWO. AND WORK WITH THEM TO
SELECT TARGET REGIONS FOR THE
PUBLICATION OF STAFF FOR
PURPOSES OF DELIVERY OF THE
SERVICES. BY AUGUST OF THIS YEAR
WE PLAN ESTABLISHES STAFFING
MODEL FOR A BETTER EMPLOYMENT
SERVICE DELIVERY AND BEGAN
RECRUITING THE EMPLOYMENT
SERVICES TEAM. BACK OVER THIS
YEAR TWENTY TWENTY TWO WOULD
PLAN FINALIZED THE SELECTION OF
THE FIRST TWO TREATMENT CENTERS.
ON FOR COLLECTING OUR STAFF THE
PLAINTIFF COMPLETED THE HIGHER
THE STAFF THAT WILL BE ASSIGNED
TO PROVIDE THE EMBEDDED
EMPLOYMENT SERVICES AT BOTH
LOCATIONS. STARTING THIS
NOVEMBER TWENTY TWENTY WE PLAN
TO CONDUCT JOINT TRAINING FOR
INCLUDING CROSS TRAINING OF
TREATMENT CENTER AND YOUR STAFF.
IN BY DECEMBER TWENTY TWO WE
PROPOSE THAT THE STAFF
COMPLICATED AND THEY WILL BEGIN
DELIVERING SERVICES AS A BETTER
MEMBERS OF THE TREATMENT TEAM.
IN THOSE TWO SELECTED CENTERS.
THEN FOLLOW UP BY THE END OF
APRIL TWENTY TWENTY THREE WHO
PLAN TO FINALIZE THE SELECTION
OF THE REMAINING TWO WHICH
CENTERS UP FOR COLLECTING STAFF.
AND THEN THROUGH A TWENTY TWENTY
THREE THROUGH THIRTY SEPTEMBER
TWENTY TWENTY THREE WERE PURPOSE
RECRUIT HIRE THE REMAINING
STAFF. CONDUCTED JOINT TRAINING
AND- EXPAND INTO THOSE SERVICES
WITH ADDITIONAL CENTERS- WE PLAN
TO BE FULLY OPERATIONAL AND
RUNNING BETWEEN OCTOBER TWENTY
TWENTY THREE THREE JAN TWENTY
TWENTY FIVE. I'M IN DELIVERING
THE SERVICES AND SUPPORTS TWO
PARTICIPANTS ARE RECEIVING
TREATMENT AND ALL FOUR OF THE
CENTERS. IS NOTED FROM CURRENTLY
THROUGH THE TERM OF THE PILOT
STARTING WITH THE COMMENCEMENT
OF SERVICES IN THE FIRST
PARTICIPANTS ARE RECEIVING THE
SERVICES. WILL BEGIN DATA
COLLECTION TO INCLUDE CUSTOMER
SATISFACTION- AND- BEFORE FOR
BOTH INDIVIDUAL ZERO POINT
SERVICES AND THE PARTICIPATING
STAFF RECEIVING TRAINING. I HAVE
AN ANSWER IF THERE ARE ANY
FURTHER QUESTIONS. THANK YOU I
WILL BRING IT BACK UP I WANT TO
FOLLOW UP A LITTLE BIT ON HOW
THOSE TREATMENT SITES ARE CHOSEN
AT THE YOU SAID THAT TO CENTERS
WILL BE CHOSEN BY THE END OF
THIS YEAR AND- TO CENTERS BY THE
END OF. NEXT YEAR- I'M HOPING
THAT WE CAN BE SENSITIVE TO THE
GEOGRAPHICAL. DISPARITIES AND-
CHALLENGES THAT. OUR STATE FACES
AND WOULD HOPE THAT IN YOUR
SELECTION OF THIS TREATMENT
CENTERS WE ARE. SIMILARLY
CHOOSING A DIVERSE. CENTERS
THROUGHOUT OUR STATE AND- I
WOULD LIKE TO HEAR YOUR THOUGHT
PROCESS AND HOW YOU WILL BE
CHOOSING THOSE SITES OR ANY
INSIGHTS THAT YOU CAN PROVIDE AT
THIS TIME. THANK YOU CHAIR-
ACTUALLY QUESTION IN FANTASTIC
POINTS ON WHICH WE ARE WE ARE
BEING PARTICULAR DELIVERED AND
SELECTING THE TREATMENT CENTERS
AND WE'RE GONNA BE USING- SOME
THE FOLLOWING CONSIDERATIONS. IS
THE TREATMENT CENTER IT IT'S
SERVING A HIGH CONCENTRATION OF
A TRADITIONALLY UNDERSERVED
POPULATION. IS THE CENTER
LOCATED IN AND SERVING A
COMMUNITY THAT'S JUST
DISPROPORTIONATELY IMPACTED BY
THE OPIOID CRISIS. DO THE SENATE
LOCATIONS REPRESENT A VARIETY
AND REGIONAL EMPLOYMENT
LANDSCAPE FOR EXAMPLE RURAL
VERSUS URBAN ECONOMIES. COMES AS
HIGH TECH OF THE ECONOMIES-
REPRESENTING VERY DIFFERENT TO
THE WORK FORCE AND A DIFFERENT
METHOD OF EMPLOYMENT AS AN
AGRICULTURAL OR A- IN. REGENT
THAT'S FOCUSED ON LOGISTICS AND
TRANSPORTATION- WE'RE ALSO
SEEKING THE CENTERS THAT ARE
INTERESTED IN INNOVATION AND
THAT THEY'RE OPEN TO PARTNERSHIP
WITH YOU ARE TO ENSURE THAT WHAT
FULL PLAN AS A PART OF THE
INITIATIVE. AS NOTED WE ARE
SEEKING TO DEMONSTRATE THE
EFFICACY OF INCLUDING APARTMENTS
SERVICES PART OF RECOVERYAND
EFFORT WE WANT. TO SELECT
LOCATIONS THERE TOO SIMILAR TO
EACH OTHER. AND AS YOU NOTED TO
CRITICS ALSO SERVE THOSE THAT
ARE MOST IN NEED SO WE REALLY
ARE- NOT BEING DELIBERATE THE
FIRST TWO WILL BE SELECTED AT IN
IN CONSULTATION AND WORK WITH
THE WITH THE- SERVICE COMMUNITY.
AS WELL AS THE SECOND TWO- THE
IDEA OUT- AS YOU KNOW WHAT IT IS
TO MAKE SURE THAT WE'RE SERVING
A BROAD RANGE OF COMMUNITIES AND
CONSERVE. THEM AND SIMILAR
LOOKING.
THIS ITEM OPEN AND WE WILL NOW
MOVE ON TO THE DEPARTMENT OF.
SOCIAL SERVICES PROPOSALS. WE
WILL START ON ISSUE EIGHT ON THE
ELECTRONIC BENEFITS TRANSFER OR
EBT FRAUD. AND THEFT PREVENTION
BCP. WE WILL HAVE THREE
PRESENTERS ON THIS PANEL OF
ISSUE EIGHT. RYAN GILLETTE THE
RESEARCH AUTOMATION AND DATA
DIVISION CHIEF. DATA STRATEGIST
FOR THE CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF
SOCIAL SERVICES. WILL BE JOINING
US ON WEBEX. JANINE DR DR. BUT
THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCING RYAN
ANDERSON WITH THE LEGISLATIVE
ANALYST'S OFFICE I UNDERSTAND
THAT WE HAVE SOME REMARKS AS
WELL FROM YANG LEAVE THE CHIEF
FINANCIAL OFFICER FOR THE
DEPARTMENT OF SOCIAL SERVICES ON
BEHALF OF. DIRECTOR KIM JOHNSON
MISTER LEAGUE CAN YOU PLEASE
BEGIN WHEN YOU ARE READY. SURE
THANK YOU. ELEVEN WITH THE
CHURCH AND MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE MY NAME IS YANG LEE
AND I'M THE CHIEF FINANCIAL
OFFICER OF DEPARTMENTS THOSE
RESOURCES IT'S MY PLEASURE UP
THANK YOU FOR ACTION HAPPINESS
HERE AND PRESENTING ON ITS
PROPOSALS IT'S MY PLEASURE TO BE
HERE ON BEHALF OF DIRECTED
JOHNSON TO OPEN UP THE
CONVERSATION ABOUT OUR APRIL ONE
FINANCE LETTERS. OUT WE'RE
REALLY GRATEFUL FOR AFTER THIS
PAST YEAR IN PARTNERSHIP THE
LEGISLATURE WE NEVER EXPAND OUT
THE PROBLEMS THAT WE HAD ADINA
BRESGE THE FOURTEEN BILLION
DOLLARS IN NEW FOR NEW PROGRAMS
AND NEW FUNNY OVER UNVESTED
CENTER DEPARTMENT SOCIAL
SERVICES THAT'S DOING A LOT OF
GREAT STUFF FOR OUR CLIENTS. WE
WANT TO ACKNOWLEDGE THAT THERE
CAN BE. WELL IT. OPERATIONAL
NEEDS AN ARGUMENT SEVENTIES
BURKE- MYSTERY PROSTHESES. AND
LOT OF BEHIND THE PARK SCENES
OVERALL SO. THESE PROPOSES THAT
WE HAVE IN FRONT OF YOU ARE
REALLY CRITICAL FOR DEPARTMENT
TO CONTINUE TO IMPLEMENT AND
ADMINISTER PROGRAMS. AND TO
PROVIDE GOOD SERVICES TO OUR
CLIENTS- MY COLLEAGUES. FROM THE
DEPARTMENT AVAIL ONLINE SO THEY
COULD. PRESENT ON THE PROPOSAL
AND ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS YOU
HAVE SO WE'RE JUST LOOKING FOR
DOWN THE CONVERSATIONS OVERALL.
TWENTY THANKED FOR THAT- SO
WE'RE GOING TO START OFF WITH
YOU MENTIONED WITH TARANTULA AND
YOU CAN PRESENT ON THE FIRST.
ISSUE SANFORD THANK YOU. RIGHT
TO LOOK. YEAH YOU MIGHT HAVE.
MISTER JULY YOU MIGHT HAVE YOUR
MICROPHONE MUTED. THE DIFFICULT
- BUT THE WEATHER. BETTER YES WE
CAN HEAR YOU NOW. OKAY GREAT-
SO- RANCH LET WITH THE RESEARCH
AUTOMATION AND DATA DIVISION-
I'M GOING TO BE PRESENTING ABOUT
THE REQUEST FOR ADDITIONAL
FUNDING FOR THE T. THAT SPECIAL
BASKET OR SO CDS THAT'S IT'S
REQUESTING ONE FULL TIME
PERMANENT SUPERVISING SPECIAL
INVESTIGATOR TO FULL TIME
PERMANENT SPECIAL INVESTIGATORS
AND ONE FULL TIME PERMANENT HEPA
TO COMBAT EVER INCREASING THIRD
PARTY E. T. APPS AS WELL AS
OTHER POTENTIAL PUBLIC
ASSISTANCE FRAUD IS NOT BEING
INVESTIGATED CURRENTLY DUE TO.
LACK OF RESOURCES STATEWIDE.
RECIPIENTS OF HEALTH QUESTION
HOW WORKS RECEIVED THEIR FOOD
AND CASH BENEFITS ON EBT CARDS
WHICH CAN THEN BE USED AT ATMS
AND OTHER POINT OF SALE DEVICES
THROUGHOUT THE STATE. RECENTLY
WE'VE SEEN THAT THERE'S BEEN A
SUBSTANTIAL INCREASE IN THIRD
PARTY THAT THE B. B. T. BENEFITS
THROUGH- TWO DIFFERENT TYPES OF
ADEPT- SKIMMING AND SCAMMING.
SKIMMING IS A FORM OF ELECTRONIC
THEFT IN WHICH ABOLISHES ACTOR
PLACES THAT DEVICE ON APPOINTED
CIRCLE A POINT OF SALE TERMINAL.
THAT CAPTURES THE CARD
INFORMATION ON CARDS THAT ARE
SCANNED AT THAT TERMINAL. AND
SCANNING THE KURDS WHEN
ABOLISHES ACTOR USES SOCIAL
ENGINEERING- TO MANIPULATE
CARDHOLDERS INTO DISCLOSING
THEIR INFORMATION. IN BOTH
INSTANCES THE MALICIOUS ACTOR
CAN THEN USE THAT CARD
INFORMATION TO CREATE A CLONE
CARD IN DROUGHT ON BENEFITS- OFF
WITH THE RIGHTFUL CARDHOLDERS
ACCOUNT. OKAY PAST EIGHTEEN
MONTHS A THIRD PARTY THAT. HAS
INCREASED FROM ABOUT FIFTY FIVE
THOUSAND PER MONTH- OVERSTATE
FISCAL YEARS NINETEEN TWENTY AND
TWENTY TWENTY ONE- TO SOMETHING
CLOSER TO THE TWO TO THREE
MILLION DOLLAR RANGE PER MONTH
OVER THE PAST COUPLE OF MONTHS.
CURRENT STATUTES IN PARTICULAR
AB TWENTY THIRTY FIVE IN AB
TWENTY THREE THIRTEEN MANDATE
THAT THE STATE REPLACE BENEFITS
THAT WERE STOLEN BY ELECTRONIC
MEANS. SUCH AS SKIMMING AD
SCAMMING- AND RESULTING CASH
REIMBURSEMENTS ARE PAID OUT OF
STATE GENERAL FUND DOLLARS. IN
ADDITION PUT THAT REIMBURSEMENTS
WERE ADDED DUE TO THE OUTCOMES
OF YOUR TAKEOVERS JOHNSON PARK
FINDINGS AND ARE ALSO PAID FROM
STATE GENERAL FUND. WHILE THE
REIMBURSEMENT LEVELS ARE NOT AS
HIGH AS THE CASH SIDE AFTER THIS
PROGRAM IS ALSO GROWING. THAT
PROPOSED POSITIONS ARE NEEDED TO
PREVENT AND DETER THE THEFT OF
EBT BENEFITS FROM VULNERABLE LOW
INCOME CALIFORNIANS. THE
REQUESTED RESOURCES WILL PROVIDE
CSS WITH DEDICATED ABILITY TO
CONDUCT INVESTIGATIONS AND
COORDINATE WITH OTHER. LOCAL AND
FEDERAL LAW ENFORCEMENT PARTNERS
THESE RESOURCE IS WHAT ALLOWS
CSS TO ADDRESS THE INCREASE IN
UNITY THEFT IN THE CALFRESH
EMPOWERS PROGRAMS. COMPLY WITH
FEDERAL REQUIREMENTS PROVIDE
ADDITIONAL OVERSIGHT AND
TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE TO
COUNTIES. AND PROTECT.
RECIPIENTS WERE BEING VICTIMIZED
EXPERIENCING LOTS OF BENEFITS.
THE STOCK MONITOR INVESTIGATE
AND SUPPORT PROSECUTION OF THIRD
PARTY EVEN TO TALK TO PUBLIC
ASSISTANCE FUNDS AT THE STATE
LEVEL.ALSO RECEIVING ADDITIONAL
PREVENTIVE MEASURES MEASURES TO
REDUCE FUTURE ACTIVITIES. TAKE
ME QUESTIONS. THANK YOU NEXT
WE'LL HEAR JENNY DR WITH THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE. I OPINION
DR DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE NO
COMMENTS AT THIS TIME. NEXT
WE'LL HEAR FROM RYAN ANDERSON
WITH THE L. L. RYAN ANDERSON
LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S OFFICE WE
REVIEWED THIS PROPOSAL AND I
HAVE NO CONCERNS AT THIS TIME.
THANK YOU I WILL BRING IT UP TO
THE DENTIST TO SEE IF ANY
MEMBERS HAVE QUESTIONS- FOR MR
GILLETTE IF I CAN I'M HOPING FOR
A LITTLE BIT MORE INFORMATION ON
THE THEFT PHENOMENON WHICH WE
ARE EXPERIENCING. AS WELL A HOW
THE RESOURCES IN THE P. C. P.
WILL BE SET UP TO XXL FULLY
BATTLE THIS SITE- NOTICED THAT
THE PROPOSAL IS FOR LESS THAN WE
ARE- LOSING WITHIN A GIVEN
MONTH. AS A COST FOR THE ENTIRE
YEAR WONDERING IF WE'RE AT THE
RIGHT CARE. TO MAKE SURE THAT WE
ARE COMBATING THIS EFFECTIVELY.
YEAH SO GREAT QUESTION- WE HAVE
SEEN AN INCREASE AND WE IN FACT
THAT AS I MENTIONED- WE ARE
STILL TRYING TO INVESTIGATE
EXACTLY. WHY THIS IS HAPPENING-
YEAH WE HAVE SOME THEORIES BUT-
INVESTIGATES AND INVESTIGATIONS
ARE ONGOING SO IT'S A LITTLE BIT
HARD TO SAY AT THIS POINT. OUR
BEST GUESS IS THAT IN THE PAST
IS THAT WOULD OBVIOUSLY BEEN
SOMETHING THAT'S BEEN PURSUED
BY. INDIVIDUAL ACTORS- AND-
THERE'S SOME EVIDENCE NOW THAT
THERE MIGHT BE. ORGANIZED IT'S A
LITTLE BIT MORE ORGANIZATION
IT'S HAPPENING BEHIND IT WITH
NO. PRIME BRAKES THAT ARE
THEY'RE GETTING INVOLVED IN THIS
WORK. WE ARE PURSUING A NUMBER
STRATEGIES TO COMBAT UP ON THE
FRONT END- SO FOR EXAMPLE WERE
PLANNING TO ROLL OUT A NEW CARD
VERIFICATION VALUE CVT
TECHNOLOGY- ON EBT CARDS- NEXT
MONTH WHICH SHOULD. BOTH BE
SUBSTANTIALLY DOWN ON THE- SIDE
OF THINGS- AND WE'RE ALSO
THINKING ABOUT WAYS THAT WE CAN
USE. THAT DATA THAT WE HAV ON
CARD USAGE TO TRY TO IDENTIFY
WHERE SOME OF THOSE SKIMMING
DEVICES MAYBE. AND ALSO GLEANING
INFORMATION THAT COULD BE USED
FOR INVESTIGATORS TO GO OUT AND
PURSUE THOSE LEADS AND TRY TO
TRACK DOWN SOME OF THE-
PERPETRATORS OF THESE CRIMES-
THESE RESOURCES WILL BE
SUBSTANTIALLY BENEFICIAL.
BECAUSE CURRENTLY WE DON'T HAVE
A LOT OF RESOURCES ON THE STATE. SIDE PURSUE WORK BEST IT.
RUSTICATED STOP I'M TO GO AND
CONDUCT THOSE THOSE-
INVESTIGATIONS WHERE WHERE THE
TOPIC. AND SO THIS IS BECOMING
MORE THAT IT IS THE STATE ISSUE
IT CAN MAKE IT DIFFICULT IF
THERE ARE JURISDICTIONAL ISSUES
THAT- YOU KNOW SOMEONE HAS THEIR
BENEFITS AS SOMEONE WHO IS A
CARD HOLDER AND I LOS ANGELES
HAS THEIR BENEFITS STOLEN BUT
THEN DRAWN DOWN FROM AN ACCOUNT
. BAY AREA- SO. WHAT WE WOULD
EXPECT IS THAT WOULD BE
SITUATIONAL DEDICATED STATE
RESOURCES WE WOULD BE ABLE TO
PURSUE MORE OF THOSE LEADS
IDENTIFY A MORE- ABOUT MALICIOUS
ACTORS AND HOPEFULLY GET SOME
ARRESTS THAT WOULD CUT DOWN ON
ON FUTURE. THANK YOU FOR THAT
I'M- I DO WANT TO DIG IN A
LITTLE BIT AS I WANT TO MAKE
SURE THAT WE ARE STRENGTHENING
THE PROGRAM WHEN WE HAVE THIS
THEFT OCCURRING- WE ARE THEN NOT
HAVING CALFRESH DOLLARS GOING
TOWARDS THEIR DESIGNATED.
PURPOSE OF ADDRESSING FOOD
INSECURITY AND SO I THINK THE
REASON OR RATIONALE FOR MY
QUESTIONING IS REALLY TO MAKE
SURE THAT HAVE THE APPROPRIATE
RESOURCES TO. PURSUE ENOUGH TO
CURTAIL THE SENATE THIS IN THE
BUD AND THAT'S REALLY WHAT I'M
ASKING OF THE ADMINISTRATION IS
IN LIGHT OF. US HAVING
SIGNIFICANTLY INCREASED. IS THIS
THE APPROPRIATE AMOUNT OF
RESOURCES FOR US TO STOP THIS
AND NIP THIS IN THE BUD OR WILL
YOU. NEED MORE IN THE FUTURE I
WOULD RATHER HAVE THAT HONEST.
CONVERSATION TODAY TO MAKE SURE
THAT WE'RE PROVIDING- THE
APPROPRIATE AMOUNT OF RESOURCES
TO ADDRESS THIS PROBLEM HEAD ON.
COMMENT FROM THE ADMINISTRATION
ON THE APPROPRIATENESS OF THIS-
THE BUDGET REQUEST. ABSOLUTELY-
SO. AS I MENTIONED BEFORE WE ARE
PURSUING OTHER EFFORTS TO ADD
SUCH AS THE CVV VALUE ADD- YOU
KNOW THESE OTHER SOFTWARE
SOLUTIONS THAT THIS THIS IS ONE
PART OF BROADER EFFORTS THAT ARE
THAT ARE UNDER WAY- YOU KNOW WE
DO BELIEVE THAT AT THIS POINT-
ASKED THAT WE HAVE IN TERMS OF
INVESTIGATIVE STAFF- WHAT. WOULD
BE. SUFFICIENT FOR THE ISLAND IS
THAT WE'VE SEEN- BUT WOULD ALSO
ADD THAT WE ARE PURSUING
ADDITIONAL FEDERAL SUPPORT FOR
PROGRAMS LIKE SNAP. I'M TO TAKE
ADVANTAGE OF. OTHER FUNDING
STREAMS ARE OUT THERE TO HELP
INCREASE THAT- YEP OF THESE
PROGRAMS. IS IT POSSIBLE FOR US
IS THE LEGISLATURE TO GET AN
UPDATE PRIOR TO NEXT YEAR TO
DETERMINE WHETHER OR NOT- WE ARE
BEING EFFECTIVE WITH THE
RESOURCES THAT WE'VE ALLOCATED
HOW WHAT WOULD BE AN APPROPRIATE
TIME FRAME. FOR US TO CHECK BACK
IN TO SEE IF WE ARE. MAKING A
SIGNIFICANT DENT ON THIS. YES WE
CAN ABSOLUTELY PROVIDE YOU WITH
REGULAR UPDATES ON- THE FAX
NUMBER IS SENT AND IF WE'RE
SEEING A DECLINE- WE WOULD HOPE
THAT AS- MORE OF THESE- EFFORTS
IN IN RESOURCES COME ONLINE WE
WOULD START TO SEE A- HOPEFULLY
PRETTY. STEEP DECLINE IN OUR
ANNUAL IN OUR MONTHLY
SEPTEMBER'S- SO WE'D BE MORE
THAN HAPPY TO PROVIDE THAT WITH.
WHATEVER PRECONCEIVED LIKE WOULD
YOU EXPECT THAT WITHIN THE NEXT
THREE MONTHS OR SIX MONTHS TO
SEE THAT SUBSTANTIAL DECLINE
BECAUSE THAT. WOULD THEN BE THE
APPROPRIATE TIME FRAME FOR US TO
ASK FOR THAT INFORMATION BACK
AND- WOULD LIKE TO HEAR FROM YOU
WHAT- YOU THINK IS WHAT YOU
WOULD BE AMENABLE TO. I WOULD I
WOULD SAY THAT SIX MONTHS WOULD
PROBABLY BE A GOOD POINT TO
CHECK IN I'M AT THAT POINT WE
SHOULD HAVE THE IT SEEMS TO BE
TECHNOLOGY- IN PLACE AND- YOU
ASSUMING THAT THE PC RESOURCES-
COME ONLINE. HOW LEADS UNDER WAY
AND THAT HAVE SOMETHING TO SHOW
FOR THAT- SO CAN DEFINITELY.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH I WILL THINK
THIS ENTIRE PANEL- MR LEE DOT
PROGRAM BUT JUST WANT TO NOTE
THAT WHEN IT COMES TO HIRING
STAFF TO TAKE SALUTE AWHILE TO
BRING PEOPLE ON TRAINING THEM TO
A- SIX MONTH IS A GOOD WAY FOR
TO CHECK IN WITH YOU. TO GIVE
YOU A- A STATUS UPDATE BUT- ONE
NOTE THAT THERE'S ALSO OF THESE
OTHER PROCESSES THAT THEY'RE
ALSO WORKING ON THAT THE
DEPARTMENTS WORKING ON ALSO. AND
BRING AN ONBOARD FOLKS SOMETIMES
TAKES A BIT LONGER THAN
ANTICIPATED TO GOING TO BE OUT
OF AB WILL COME IN AND TRAIN
THEM MAKE SURE THEY'RE DOING THE
WORK AND WE CAN. YOU KNOW GET
YOU MORE INFORMATION ON. SOME
GREAT I WILL. THIS ENTIRE. WE
WILL HOLD THIS ITEM OPEN AND
WILL NOW MOVE ON TO ISSUE TEN.
WHICH IS ON THE CHILD AND FAMILY
SERVICES. EXCUSE ME WE WILL NOW
MOVE ON TO ISSUE NINE WHICH IS
ON THE STRENGTHENING EMERGENCY
CAPACITY AND CAPABILITIES BCP.
WE WILL HAVE THREE PRESENTERS
ON. THE PANEL FOR ISSUE NINE WE
WILL BEGIN WITH J. R. AND TUB
AND TOPLEY IN. THE DISASTER
SERVICES BRANCH CHIEF FOR CDSS
FOLLOWED BY JEANINE DR WITH
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE RYAN
ANDERSON WITH THE L. A. L. LET'S
START WITH CHAIR ON TOP LEON. TO
BEGIN THE PANEL FOR ISSUE NINE
WHEN YOU ARE READY. THANK YOU.
AND GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIR ON ONE
MEMBERS OF THE SUBCOMMITTEE. MY
NAME IS KEREN CHAPLAIN I AM THE
CHIEF OF THE DEBT IS AFTER
SERVICES BLANCHARD CDS US.
EXCUSE ME CDSS REQUESTING TWELVE
PERMANENT POSITIONS TO SUPPORT
THE DIVESTITURES BRANCH IN
ADDRESSING POTENTIAL MASS CARE
AND SHELTER FUNCTIONS WERE
AFFECTED DISASTER PLANNING
RESPONSE AND RECOVERY
OPERATIONS. THE REQUIRED
RESOURCES WILL STRENGTHEN
LEADERSHIP OVERSIGHT AND
ADMINISTRATIVE FUNCTIONS EXPAND
OR BUILD OPERATIONS UNIT TO
SUPPORT RE REGIONAL AREAS WHICH
WOULD MIMIC THE GOVERNOR'S
OFFICE OF EMERGENCY SERVICES-
THREE REGIONAL AREAS INLAND
COASTAL AND SOUTHERN. THESE
POSITIONS WILL ALLOW US TO PLACE
FIVE EMPLOYEES- PHYSICALLY IN
THE SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA REGION
JOB MORE QUICKLY RESPOND TO
DISASTERS. THE REMAINING
POSITIONS WOULD EXPAND A
RECOVERY OPERATION TO LEVERAGE
STATE AND FEDERAL DISASTER
ASSISTANCE PROGRAMS AND FUNDING.
LYCURGUS AFTER CASE MANAGEMENT
PROGRAM WHICH PROVIDES SERVICES
TO PEOPLE THAT HAVE BEEN
AFFECTED BY A DISASTER. OUR
STATE SUPPLEMENTAL BRICK
PROGRAM. AND THE TRANSITIONAL
SHELTERING ASSISTANCE THANK- AS
WELL AS OUR PEOPLE
REIMBURSEMENTS- WITH THIS AFTER
THE CURRENT MORE OFTEN LASTING
LONGER MORE RESOURCES ARE NEEDED
TO PROP WITH. THOSE EXPENSES
THAT APPLY FOR B. MARIE BURKE.
CHAU BROUGH RECOUPING ALL OF
OUR- COSTS. AT THIS TIME THAT IS
ALL I HAPPEN THREE. WILL BRING
IT UP TO DYESS ANY MEMBER
QUESTIONS- AGAIN JUST.
CONSISTENT WITH WHERE WERE
PREVIOUS ISSUE HOPING TO GET A
TIMELINE FOR ACHIEVING AND
EXPECTED OUTCOMES WHICH ARE
LISTED IN THE AGENDA- AS WELL AS
HOW THE ADMINISTRATION ARRIVED
AT THE LEVEL OF REQUESTED STAFF.
AND HOME MANY OF THE STAFF ARE
CURRENTLY RESOURCE WITHIN OUR
BASELINE BUDGET WOULD BE
IMPORTANT INFORMATION FOR US TO
HAVE. SURE YES THAT WE CURRENTLY
HAVE APPROXIMATELY. TEN TO
TWELVE STOPPER CURRENTLY IN
THOSE POSITIONS I'M ALL OF THOSE
POSITIONS BUT ONE ARE LOCATED
IN. THE SACRAMENTO AREA TO
SUPPORT THE ENTIRE STATE OF THIS
WOULD GIVE US- FIVE ADDITIONAL
POSITIONS BUT THEN. MIMICKING IN
THOSE AREAS THE CALORIE S. HAVE
BY PLACING FIVE FOUR AND ONE
REGION WHICH WOULD BE MORE OF
THE NORTH. OF PIPER COASTAL AND
THEN FIVE OR SOUTHERN I'M SO
GIVE US ABOUT FIVE ADDITIONAL
FROM THE TEN TO ELEVEN THAT WE
CURRENTLY HAVE. OUR GOAL TO.
ACCOMPLISH THE ITEMS THAT WE
MENTIONED I WOULD BE ABOUT TWO
TO THREE YEARS AFTER HIRING.
THESE POSITIONS IF WE WERE TO
GET UP. I'M AND I THAT WHAT
THEY'RE THIRD QUESTION I. GOT NO
I THINK YOU INTO IT- I WILL NOW
THE BRING JEANINE DR WITH
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE FOLLOWED
BY RYAN ANDERSON WITH ALIA. I
DIDN'T DOCTOR FINANCE NO
CONCERNS FROM FINANCE AT THIS
TIME. RYAN ANDERSON WITH THE L.
L. RYAN ANDERSON AVAIL THE
AWESOME CONCERNS. WITH THAT I
WILL THANK MUCH THIS PANEL WE
WILL HOLD THIS ITEM OPEN AND WE
WILL NOW MOVE ON TO ISSUE TEN ON
THE CHILD AND FAMILY SERVICES
ACUTE REVIEW AND RESPONSE BCP WE
WILL HAVE THREE PRESENTERS ON
THIS ISSUE BEGINNING WITH ANGIE
SCHWARTZ WITH THE CHILDREN AND
FAMILY SERVICES DIVISION DEPUTY
DIRECTOR FOR CDSS. FOLLOWED BY
JUSTIN FREED US WITH THE WITH
THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE AND
PERSON WITH THE L. L. LET'S
START WITH ANGIE SPORTS WHEN YOU
ARE READY. THANK YOU GOOD
AFTERNOON CHAIR ARAMBULA AND
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE MY NAME
DANTE SHORT FROM THE DEPUTY
DIRECTOR FOR THE CHILDREN AND
FAMILY SERVICES DIVISION AT THE
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT SPECIAL
CERVANTES. WHAT'S BEING TO STAFF
SERVICE MANAGER ONE SPECIALIST
POSITION TO REVIEW AND RESPOND
TO STATEWIDE TRENDS AND EMERGING
EIGHTY AND WHILE BEING
CONCERNED. HER CHILDREN INVOLVED
IN OUR CHILD WELFARE SYSTEM.
PDFS OF IDENTIFIED TRENDS
INCLUDING THAT IN SOME PARTS THE
STATE CHILDREN UNDER THE AGE OF
SIX. I THINK STAYS IN SOLITARY
BEYOND THE MAXIMUM TIME
PERMITTED. AND MANY YEARS HER
STAYING IN OUR SHORT TERM
RESIDENTIAL THERAPEUTIC PROGRAM
LONGER THAN IS NECESSARY TO MEET
THEIR TREATMENT NEEDS. ONE
SIGNIFICANT EFFORTS. SUCH AS
THESE ARE IDENTIFIED THE
DEPARTMENT REDIRECT STAFF
FIFTEEN CRITICAL WORK FOR
TEMPORARY PERIOD IN ORDER TO
CONDUCT CASE REVIEWS AND
ANALYSES. AND PROVIDE TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE AND SUPPORT TO
RESOLVE THE UNDERLYING ISSUE.
THE PERMANENT POSITION WE ARE
REQUESTING WOULD ALLOW THE
DEPARTMENT TO CREATE A DEDICATED
RESPONSE TEAM THAT WOULD PLAN
FOR AND MANAGE THE SITUATION AND
ALSO BE ABLE TO PROVIDE MORE
PROACTIVE RECOMMENDATIONS. TO
MAINTAIN. CHILD BAIT THE TRAP
CALIFORNIA. I DON'T KNOW WHAT
THE PARTNER BUT HIGH LEVEL.
REGARDING FROM BUT AREA ALL
MEDICARE THE COST COMP.
ASSOCIATED WITH THE FINING LINE
BACKSTOPS BEAT ACTIVITY. WOULD
ALSO BE ABLE TO BETTER DETECT AN
ISSUE BEFORE IT SPREADS AND USE
DATA IN CASE REVIEW MORE
PROACTIVELY TO DRIVE ACTION TO
DIRECT PROGRESSIVE AND EQUITABLE
CHILD WELFARE POLICY. IN
ADDITION TO IMPROVING CHILDREN'S
LIVES THAT THAT THAT THAT'S WORK
WELL OFTEN DECREASE POTENTIAL
LIABILITY FOR CALIFORNIA RELATED
TO THE NEED FOR SUCH OVERSIGHT.
THE PROPOSAL SUPPORT THE LONGER
TERM GOALS OF IDENTIFYING AND
ADDRESSING CRITICAL CONCERNS
WITHIN OUR CHILD WELFARE SYSTEM
AND IF RESOURCES ARE NOT A PRINT
YES THAT'S CORRECT FALLING OUT
OF COMPLIANCE WITH MANY STATE
AND FEDERAL MANDATES- ON THE
FIRST TWO YEARS OF
IMPLEMENTATION. THE SHORT TERM
OUTCOMES MAY APPEAR COUNTER
INTUITIVE IN THAT MORE ADVERSE
EXPERIENCES ACTUALLY MAY BE
DISCOVERED AND INVESTIGATED BUT
ULTIMATELY WE EXPECT TO SEE A
DECREASE THAT DECREASE. IN THE
FREQUENCY AT THE UNDERPASS
UNDESIRABLE EXPERIENCES FOR OUR
CHILDREN AND WITHIN OUR FOSTER
CARE SYSTEM VERY GRATEFUL FOR
YOUR CONSIDERATION OF THIS
PROPOSAL. AND HAPPY TO ANSWER
ANY QUESTIONS. THANK YOU WILL%
BRING IN DEPARTMENT AFFECTS. YES
DOESN'T GREATEST FIND OUT
COMMENT WILL SAY IS THAT WERE-
HAPPY TO TAKE INTO
CONSIDERATION. THE LEGISLATURE
IS A COMMENTS AND QUESTIONS
LISTED THE AGENDA BOB BUDGET
BILL LANGUAGE. THANK YOU RYAN
ANDERSON WITH THE L. L.
REINERTSEN LA- WE'VE REVIEWED
THIS PROPOSAL AND NO CONSENT TO
SUCH. CONCERNS SURE. THANK YOU I
WILL BRING IT UP TO THE DYESS
AND KEEP IT HERE FOR NOW- MISS
SHORTS I WAS HOPING YOU COULD
EXPLAIN A LITTLE BIT THE STATUS
OF THE LICENSED AND- UNLICENSED
S. T. R. T. P.'S. ARE WE
CURRENTLY HAVING CHILDREN IN OUR
UNLICENSED S. T. R. T. P.'S AND
IF SO. HOW MANY AND WHY. I DON'T
BELIEVE WE HAVE ANY YOU'D BETTER
AN UNLICENSED S. T. R. T. PEACE
AT THIS TIME WE DO HAVE THE
EFFECT ON TIME AND I'M LICENSE.
SETTING BUT LIKE IN IN AN OFFICE
OR SOMETHING LIKE THAT BUT THERE
AREN'T WE DON'T HAVE USED THAT
ARE STAYING IN I MIGHT ASK YOUR
GP- WE DO HAVE SOME NEXT YEAR TO
KEEP IT WILL HAVE- PROVISIONAL
LICENSURE BECAUSE THEY'RE TRYING
TO GET THEIR MENTAL HEALTH
CONTRACT SOMEPLACE. BUT THAT
IT'S A LIFE AND- FETTING WHAT
WE'RE- IS YOU'D BETTER OVER-
THAT THAT YOUR T. P. MORE THE
CREATED THEY SHOULD BE IN THE T.
IN ORDER TO MAKE THEIR- NEEDS.
I'M TELLING HAVING AT DIFFICULT
TIME FIGURING OUT WHY THAT NOT
PLACEMENT BE FOR THAT YOUNG
PERSON IN A COMMUNITY SETTING
WHICH IS WHAT THE STATUTE
REQUIRES THERE'S GENERALLY SIX
MONTHS- LIMIT ON THE F. T. P.
PLACEMENT WITH SOME ABILITY TO
EXPAND BEYOND AFFECT PLANS- BUT
REALLY THE GOAL IS TO MEET THE
IMMEDIATE TREATMENT NEEDS THAT
THE YOUNG PERSON AND GET THEM
BACK INTO A COMMUNITY. I THINK.
I'D LIKE TO FOLLOW UP AND
REQUEST THE BBL TO BE ADOPTED IN
THIS P. IF POSSIBLE. AS THAT
WOULD AID IN THE TRANSPARENCY IN
ACCOUNTING LETY CORRECT SHELTER
AND S. T. R. T. P. OVERSTAYS. I
WANT TO ENSURE THAT WE'RE SEEING
THESE NUMBERS CHANGE IN THE
RIGHT DIRECTION OVER TIME AND
WOULD LIKE TO ASK IF THE.
ADMINISTRATION IS AMENABLE TO
THIS. THE ACTUALLY WHAT TO
PROVIDE REGULAR ON THE CHEMO.
THANK YOU AT COULD- JUST PRAISED
LEVINE HIM AS A STATE EARLIER
CAN'T MAKE A COMMITMENT THIS
TIME- TAKE BACK AND- THANK YOU
VERY MUCH TO THIS PANEL WE WILL
HOLD THIS ITEM OPEN AND WE WILL
NOW MOVE ON TO OUR LAST.
DISCUSSION WHICH IS ISSUE ELEVEN
ON THE HOME CARE FUND LOAN
FORGIVENESS REQUEST. WE WILL
HAVE THREE PRESENTERS ON THIS
ISSUE BEGIN BEGINNING WITH KEVIN
GAINES COMMUNITY CARE. LICENSING
DIVISION DEPUTY DIRECTOR WITH
CDSS. FOLLOWED BY A NON NAY
BECAUSE HE WITH THE DEPARTMENT
OF FINANCE AND- JACQUELYN BUT
OSSEO WITH THE L. A. L. LET'S
START WITH KEVIN GAINS WHEN YOU
ARE READY. VENTURA AS CHAIR
VOLLEYBALL COMMITTEE MEMBERS
KILLING GAMES ON COMMUNITY CARE
LICENSING DIVISION CSS ARE JUST
OF THIS WONDERFUL CALLS LAWLER
REQUESTING FORGIVENESS ON
REMAINDER ALONG EIGHT SO THE
WHOLE CARE. I'M IN THE GYM FUND
AT THE IN SANTA OF THE THAT THE
WHOLE CARE PROGRAM THANK YOU.
TWENTY SIX ONCE. UNDER THE
PROPOSAL THE WHOLE CARE WILL
RETAIN PROCESS. FIVE POINTS NO
THAT WERE OTHERWISE BE TRYING TO
THE- FUND OVER OF THE EIGHT
YEARS ON THE- WERE OBSERVED A-
ON OF. IN THE PROPOSAL SURE-
SHORT TERM OF THE FUND- WHILE
WE'RE SIR FOR OF NARROWING AND
ASSESSING HELLO ALL TERM
SOLUTION SIDE SO THAT. MOM THAT
SIMPLY WHAT WE WHICH I TO DEAL
HAVE THE SAFETY. A QUESTION THAT
YOU. THANK YOU DEPARTMENT OF
FINE. THE WITH THE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE AND I THINK AT THIS TIME
HAPPY TO TAKE ANY QUESTIONS
THANK YOU HELLO. JACKIE PRESS
ABOUT THE LEGISLATIVE ANALYST
SAYS AS NOTED IN YOUR AGENDA
WE'VE HAD SOME CONVERSATIONS
WITH THE ADMINISTRATION
REGARDING THIS PROPOSED BILL.
AND STOP STANDING THAT ONE OF
THE REASONS WHY THEY'RE SEEKING
A LOAN FORGIVENESS IS BECAUSE
THEY ARE PROJECTING- FEVER THESE
AND THE FUNDS TO DECLINE IN THE
BUDGET. FOR WE- ARE FOLLOW HIM
NOT TO BE. WAITING TO HEAR BACK
ON SOME OF THE REASONS WHY. WE
MAY BE DOING THE FAVOR OF UNEASE
TO BE DECLINING- BT ALSO THAT
RAISES BIGGER. LARGER CONCERNS
AROUND THE SELF SUFFICIENCY OF
THE FUND IF WE ARE SEEING THAT
REVENUES ARE DECLINING. SO IT
ENDED TO HER FOLLOW UP WE ALSO
POSED A SO ASK THE FEASIBILITY.
BROTHER IN FOR IN THE LONG RUN
EVAN THAT RIGHT NOW WE'RE
DEALING WITH PROJECTS. NOT NOW
WITH AVENUES WILL ACT COME AND
LOW- AS IN ALL. PAUSING PAYMENTS
WERE WE'VE DONE IN THE PAST ON.
WE AND THERE'S YEARS WERE WE
DIDN'T A LOT LOAN REPAYMENT- AT
AND THEN ALSO ADDITION TO THAT
I'M SEEKING OF REPORT BACK TO
THE LEGISLATURE NEXT YEAR- ONCE
WE GET A BETTER SENSE OF REVENUE
TRENDS. THAT WE CAN DEAL WITH
MORE ABOUT THE LARGER QUESTION
OF THE SUSTAINABILITY OF THE FUN
DURING THAT IT IS SUSTAINABLE.
IF YOU'RE GOING TO. THANK YOU I
WILL BRING IT UP TO THE HIGHEST
FOR ANY MEMBER QUESTIONS I WILL
ASK MISTER GAINES TO COMMENT ON
THE L. A. O.'S- COMMENTS IF I
CAN'T ON WHETHER OR NOT THE FEE
REVENUE S OUR SAYING ENOUGH- HI
AS WELL AS NOT AT THEN BRING
QUITE SELF SINCE OF THE- HOPING
YOU CAN PROVIDE. MINISH
COMMENTS. SO WE ARE REGARDING
THE- ON THE RECORD IT WILL
FEATURE A FINAL VOTE. ARE YOU.
IT'S BUDGET YEAR. UNLESS THAT
ARE ALEXION'S ON THE LOWER THAN
EXPECTED BECAUSE- FONG CHEERS
RIGHT NOW IS THE L. ALL HOME
CARE WORKERS. NOT ALL HER OR
AKHRAS LYFT AS AS WELL. I COULD
FROM THE ADMINISTRATION WERE
DEVELOPING US FOR ADDRESSING
ISSUE WILL. ARE YOU IT TO THIS
BODY IN A SORRY AT SEVEN. OF
PASTA- ADDITIONAL NUMBER OF OUR
RECORDS- HOLD EIGHT AS DECREASED
THE FACT THAT IT THAT HAS. ADDED
TO SHORTAGES WITHIN THE H. THOSE
ARE ALL ORGANIZATION WHAT
MEASURE AND TOGETHER THE RELY
CONTROL FACTOR TO THE DECREASED
- OUR RENEWAL AND SUCH WRITTEN
FEES OFF FROM THE OUTSIDE
ORGANIZATIONS.
AND SO YOU KNOW WE MAY HAVE GAS
- THIS THE CLIENT IS FOLLOWING
THE TREND OF AVERAGE APPLICATION
RENEWAL RATES IN THE PAST FIVE
YEARS COMBINED WITH A LOT OF.
LOAN OF PROJECTING LOCATION SO
WE'RE NOT SEEING- WE'RE SEEING
BOLGER ORGANIZATIONS. SETTING UP
TO BECOME LICENSE AS WE HOPE IT
WILL. ALL RIGHT WATCH. ARAMBULA
MAY I TO THAT PLEASE. THANK YOU
I WOULD ALSO WANT TO REALLY
EMPHASIZE THAT THE
ADMINISTRATION IS REALLY
ACTIVELY LOOKING AND EVALUATING
BOTH THE EXPENDITURES AND
REVENUES- FOR THIS FUN AND
LOOKING AT THAT THE BIG PICTURE-
JUST WANT TO REITERATE- KIND OF
THE NEED FOR THE LOAN
FORGIVENESS IN TERMS OF- HOW THE
PROPOSAL IS CURRENTLY STRUCTURED
WITH THAT THE TIMING AND THE
AMOUNT BASED ON BASED ON OUR
PROJECTIONS WE REALLY DO BELIEVE
THAT THE PROPOSAL AS IT STANDS.
IS NEEDED TO REALLY SUPPORT AND
STABILIZE THE FUND. I THINK OUR
CONCERN HERE AT THE LEGISLATURE
IS THE LONG TERM SOLVENCY OF
THIS FUND IN THE US WILL. WANT
AGAIN SOME TYPE OF REPORTING
BACK TO THE LEGISLATURE.
ESPECIALLY AS WE HEARD THAT THE
ADMINISTRATION WILL BE PURSUING
ACTIONS- THAT MAY HELP US TO
HAVE MORE OF THESE HOME CARE
FACILITIES PURSUING LICENSING. I
THINK IT SOUNDS APPROPRIATE FOR
US TO BE INVOLVED AS THOSE. AS
THAT INFORMATION IS COMING BACK
TO US SO- WITH THAT I WILL.
THANK VERY MUCH THIS ENTIRE
PANEL WE WILL HOLD THIS ITEM
OPEN. AND I WILL TAKE A SECOND
TO THANK ALL OF OUR PANELISTS IF
THERE ARE NO ADDITIONAL COMMENTS
FOR. MEMBERS QUESTIONS WE WILL
NOW BEGIN PUBLIC COMMENT. AS A
REMINDER WE WELCOME PUBLIC
COMMENT ON ANY ISSUE ON THE
AGENDA. WE DO HAVE A SUBSTANTIAL
NUMBER OF PEOPLE WHO WOULD LIKE
TO PROVIDE PUBLIC COMMENT AND
THEREFORE I WANT TO URGE YOU. TO
KEEP YOUR COMMENTS BRIEF SO THAT
WE CAN HEAR FROM EVERYONE. WE
WILL START WITH ANY IN PERSON
PUBLIC COMMENT IN THE HEARING
ROOM. SEEING NONE WE WILL NOW GO
TO THE PHONE LINE FOR PUBLIC
COMMENT. AS A REMINDER THE PHONE
NUMBER TO CONNECT IS ON THE
COMMITTEE WEBSITE AND SHOULD BE
ON THE SCREEN IF YOU ARE
WATCHING. OVER THE INTERNET THE
NUMBER AGAIN IS TOLL FREE ONE
EIGHT SEVEN SEVEN. SIX NINE TWO
EIGHT NINE FIVE SEVEN AND THE
ACCESS CODE IS ONE THREE ONE
FIVE FOUR FOUR FOUR. IF YOU
ENCOUNTER ANY PROBLEMS YOU CAN
CONTACT ASSEMBLY BUDGET
COMMITTEE AT NINE ONE SIX THREE
ONE NINE. TWENTY NINETY NINE AND
A STAFF MEMBER WILL ASSIST YOU-
WE ARE READY TO BEGIN PUBLIC
COMMENT. FOR THOSE WHO WISH TO
MAKE A COMMENT PLEASE PRESS ONE
THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME PRESS ONE
ENTERED THIS TIME IF YOU WISH TO
MAKE A COMMENT. OF COURSE. TO
LINE FOURTEEN. THANK YOU MY NAME
IS MARTY AMADO- A FAMILY MEMBER
OF AN OLDER THIS TO HAD
DEVELOPMENTAL DISABILITIES THE
PASSED AWAY SEVERAL YEARS AGO
NOT THAT ENDED FAMILY MEMBER
UNPAID CARE GIVER TO A TWENTY
NINE YEAR OLD YOUNG MAN WITH
THE- DOWN TO CONFIRM WE LIVED
WITH ME AND ALSO A MEMBER OF THE
DEVELOPMENTAL. PASSPORT AND THE
MASTER PLAN BREAKING UP
COMMITTEES- JUST WANTED TO
EXPRESS STRONG SUPPORT FOR THE-
PROPOSAL FOR THE DIVISION OF
COMMUNITY AT THE TENT RESOLUTE
IN AND- AND TECH DEPARTMENT AND
THE TEAM AND WORKING WITH US TO
TAKE OLDER ALSO MONICA UP THANK
YOU- MISTER ABDULLAH FOR LINKING
THE ISSUE- UNDER THE CALIFORNIA
HEALTH AND HUMAN SERVICES AGENCY
TODAY YOU TOO ONE IN THREE IN
LINKING THEM- TO THE PROPOSAL
WHEN THE OTHER. ISSUE THE
EQUITY- FOR PEOPLE DIVERSE. THE
WHOLE PERSON. WE I'M WILLING
THAT YOU YOU AND UP STEP ALWAYS
WHO THE NEW ARIENS. ED AS OF NOW
MEMBER I KNOW HAND YOU KNOW THE
PAST TWENTY YEARS THAT. LINE BUT
WE WANT IS NOT TO FIGHT FOR
SERVICE BUT THE HELP WHEN WE IT.
AND LASTLY. ON A DAY THAT
IMPLEMENT ME EVERYTHING AND YOU
YOUR POINT MR ARAMBULA- WHATEVER
WE CAN DO TO WORK WITH THE
SUBCOMMITTEE AND THE
SUBCOMMITTEE STAFF. ON OVERSIGHT
IS CRITICAL MAKING THE WORK AND
AGAIN THANK YOU TO OPT COMMITTEE
STAFF AND ALSO TO THE L. A. O.
FOR ALL THE WORK YOU DO AND TO
YOU MISTER RATLIFF. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. OPERATOR NOT COLOR.
NOW GO TO LIVE. SIX THANK YOU MR
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS KATHY
SANDERLING MCDONNELL WITH THE
COUNTY WELFARE DIRECTORS
ASSOCIATION COMMENTING ON IF YOU
CAN WE HAVE NO POSITION ON THE
PROPOSED B. C. P. HOWEVER I DO
WANT TO KNOW THE INTERSECTION OF
THIS REQUEST WITH SEVERAL OF THE
BUDGET REQUESTED TO GET MEDIA
HAS PUT FORTH REGARDING THE NEED
TO SUPPORT A BROADER ARRAY OF
PLACEMENTS AND SERVICES FOR
CHILDREN IN OUR CARE WHICH WOULD
ENABLE COUNTIES TO AVOID OVER
DAYS OF EMERGENCY PLACEMENTS. AS
CHAIR T. P. AND OTHER PLACES FOR
CHILDREN OF ALL AGES THE
LEGISLATURE HAS SUPPORTED
NUMEROUS PRIOR EFFORTS TO EXPAND
GRAYSON TO SERVICES THAT HAVE
YET TO BE IMPLEMENTED BY THE
STATE FOR EXAMPLE THE STATUS GET
THE COMPLETE REPORT REQUIRED BY
AB TWENTY EIGHTY THREE FACTORED
TO TWENTY EIGHTEEN. IF THERE.
ARE NO GAPS OUR SYSTEM CARE
PROPOSAL AND YOU. THAT REPORT TO
ENJOY. TWO TWENTY. A SECOND
REPORT REQUIRED BY THE SAME BILL
TO PROVIDE A MULTI YEAR PLAN FOR
INCREASING HAMA INFORMED CARE TO
ARE YOU. WITH YOU IN MID TWENTY
TWENTY AND ALSO HAS NEVER BEEN
ISSUE. AND WE HAVE YET TO SEE AN
R. X. P. EVEN BE RELEASED FOR
THE DEVELOPMENT OF A CONTINUUM
OF CARE PILOT. MEANT TO SERVE
OUR HIGHEST NEEDS YOU WE SHOULD
HAVE BEEN FUNDED AND GOING BY
THE END OF MARCH. WE ALWAYS
UNDERSTAND THE DESIRE FOR
GREATER ACCOUNTABILITY FOR
COUNTIES. BUT THE TYPES OF
AFRICA WE'VE BEEN ASKING THE
STATE FOR IN SOME CASES NOW FOR
YEARS. WELL DOCTOR FIRST OF MORE
TIMELY WE VENTURE TO SAVE YOUR
CHILDREN BE IN THE TYPES OF
SITUATION THE BC PEOPLE PORT TO
ADDRESS. ACCOUNTABILITY SHOULD
BE A TWO WAY STREET THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. THANKS CALLER PLEASE
. I KNOW THE ROOM. FOR THOSE OF
YOU WHO WISH TO. PLEASE PRESS
ONE THEN ZERO. TO GO TO LYING TO
TELL. HI GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIRMAN
. PAT WHALEN WILL OF THE HERE ON
OF YOUR NECK UHC P. YOU KNOW IS
IN SUPPORT OF THE WHICH THEM
INTEGRATE HEALTH CARE PROVIDER
PLAY A LARGER ROLE IN THE
STATE'S MEDICAL PROGRAM.
INCLUDING CARING FOR FOSTER
CHILDREN THE DUAL ELIGIBLES AND
OTHER LOW INCOME CALIFORNIANS
WHO RELY ON THE MEDICAL PRO
MEDICAL PROGRAM TO GET THEIR
COVERAGE AND CARE. UNDER A
SINGLE CONTRACT KAISER
PERMANENTE A WILL BE DIRECTLY
ACCOUNTABLE TO THE STATE FOR
DELIVERING QUALITY. SERVICE
ACCESS AND WHOLE PERSON CARE IN
ALL TE AREAS WHERE THEY
CURRENTLY EXIST AND THIS WILL BE
AN IMPORTANT ASPECT OF THE
OVERALL EFFORT TO TRANSFORM AND
ELEVATE. THE MEDICARE PROGRAM.
SO THAT IT WORKS BETTER FOR
PATIENTS ACROSS THE CONTINUUM OF
CARE. ADDITIONALLY A SINGLE
CONTRACT WILL REDUCE
ADMINISTRATIVE COMPLEXITY AND
UNNECESSARY CAR. OUR NURSES AND
HEALTHCARE WORKERS AND PATIENT
ADVOCATES WERE AT THE BEDSIDE
AND BEYOND AND WE LOOK FORWARD
TO SERVING THE CURRENT AND
FUTURE MEDICAL PATIENTS AT KP
THANKS VERY MUCH FOR
CONSIDERATION. THANK YOU NEXT
CALLER PLEASE. SURE WE HAVE ONE
ADDITIONAL PERSON TO SIGNAL BY
WHICH TO SPEAK JUST A MOMENT.
AND WE'RE GONNA GO TO LINE
TWENTY SEVEN. GOOD AFTERNOON MY
NAME IS AMY WHAT'S GOING ON THE
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF THE
ASSOCIATION OF REGIONAL CENTER
AGENCIES WE WORK WITH ALL TWENTY
ONE REGIONAL CENTERS IN THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA SUPPORT
APPROXIATELY FOUR HUNDRED
THOUSAND INDIVIDUALS WITH
DEVELOPMENTAL DISABILITIES. I'M
CALLING TODAY IN RELATION TO BE-
THE PROPOSAL THAT WOULD HURT
RELATED TO THE DIVISION OF
COMMUNITY ASSISTANCE AND
RESOLUTION. ABOUT ALL SERVICES
ARE GOT THE WHAT LEVEL BECAUSE
IT PROVIDES A BALANCED APPROACH
TO MODERNIZING THE APPEALS
PROCESS FOR DEVELOPMENTAL
SERVICES. REGIONAL CENTERS CAN
ONLY DO THEIR WORK WHEN THEY
WORK CLOSELY AND COLLABORATIVELY
WITH THE INDIVIDUAL THEY SUPPORT
AND TEIR FAMILIES AND BE
PROPOSED TO UPDATE TO THE
CURRENT PROCESS WILL HELP TO
ENHANCE THE- RELATIONSHIP.
BETWEEN REGIONAL. A SUPPORT EVEN
IN MY OF DAY. WE DO THAT THERE
ARE A OF THINGS THAT WE WENT OUT
BE CONSIDERED AS BEST PROPOSED.
IS WINDING UP WAY THROUGH THE
PROCESS. THE FIRST IN THE
TIMELINE FOR EXAMPLE. WE KNOW
THAT CHANGING PROCESS SEASON
CHANGING. THE WAY THAT WE
APPROACH THESE SORTS OF THINGS
WILL TAKE SOME ADDITIONAL TIME
SO WOULD CAUTION THAT A JULY
FIRST IMPLEMENTATION DATE OR
THIS VERY LARGE POLICY CHANGE IS
PROBABLY NOT REALISTIC AND WITH
THANK THAT JANUARY FIRST TWENTY
TWENTY THREE IS MORE REALISTIC.
ADDITIONALLY THESE ADDITIONAL
STEPS THAT ARE BEING PROPOSED
FOR INCLUSION IN THE- RESULT OUR
APPEAL PROCESS. WILL- THAT'S
ADDITIONAL WERE ON THE PART OF
REGIONAL CENTER STAFF AND SO WE
WOULD ASK THAT COST AND- THOSE
ADDITIONAL RESPONSIBILITIES THE
REQUIREMENTS IT CONSIDERED
THROUGHOUT THE PROCESS. THANK
YOU FOR YOUR TIME THIS
AFTERNOON. THANK YOU. MISTER
CHAIR THERE IS NO ONE OUT TO
SIGNAL BUT THEY WISH TO SPEAK
THANK YOU OPERATOR WILL TAKE
THAT AS THE CONCLUSION OF PUBLIC
COMMENT FOR TODAY WILL TAKE A
MOMENT TO THANK ALL OF OUR
PANELISTS- IN PARTICULAR THE
ADMINISTRATION AND THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE AND THE L.
A. O. I WOULD TO THANK ALL OF.
THIS PREPARED THE AGENDA AND-
HEARING MATERIALS TODAY FOR THE
ENTIRE YEAR BUT ALSO WANT TO
THANK DGS TACK AS WELL AS OUR
SERGEANTS. FOR ENSURING THAT WE
HAVE A CLEAN FACILITY A SAFE
FACILITY AND CAN DISTRIBUTE THIS
INFORMATION. BUT MOST
IMPORTANTLY I WANT TO THANK THE
PUBLIC WHO WE ALL SERVE AND WHO
MAKES OUR PROCESS BETTER. WITH
THAT WE ARE ADJOURNED FOR THE
DAY HAVE A GOOD DAY.